at the end of time
[Music]
13 o'clock
well hey everybody what's going on it's
Wednesday yeah and it's a [__]
monsoon it's coming down out there yeah
well I drove through two of those like
on the way home yeah so and now it's
here it's the difference if the stream
cuts out it's not you it's because
Florida got [__] Flushed Away during
the monsoon season it's like usual yeah
this happens like every [__] day yeah
somebody in the comment section who is
in the comment section I think it was
Victorian Victor says uh well you know
good thing because over here it's 130
degrees 103 103 degrees I said 130.
let's say it is 103 here too yeah I was
like I got news for each other yeah and
it's a monster and Florida's a [__]
sauna and like I said that's the thing
it's when it storms here in Florida it
doesn't really cool it off sometimes
it'll cool it off like while it's
happening but then as soon as it's over
it'll be even hotter like afterwards
yeah it'll it'll the downpour it'll be
100 degrees
there's a downpour cold
water hitting you if you're on a
motorcycle which a lot of times I'm on a
motorcycle the time is just [__] it's
miserable just soaking wet to the Bone
instantly
like a wall of water hits you almost
unexpectedly and it's [__] cold
and then it's gone 10 minutes later
and then it's [__] hot man it's
humidity is a hundred percent it's and
it just it gets worse
you're in Dagobah
yeah it's just like you're in that sauna
and somebody threw water on the Rocks
it's like that and you can't leave yeah
and what and it when it cooled off it
didn't cool off that much it would cool
off down to about 80 but it would maybe
75 but it would seem cold compared to
what it was
you know just a few minutes before
then the [__] passes and then the heat
then the heat comes right back it's just
miserable wet hot just [__]
terrible
everything fogs up your visor fogs up
all glass fogs up I have to every single
morning I have to go out like before I
leave and I have to wipe all the
condensation like off all my car windows
right because I can't see and then all
the house windows even then like I drive
it and then it fogs up again so I have
to keep like all the house windows have
water beaded up on them in the morning
yeah it's [__] bad it's just it only
lasts you know this is only gonna last a
couple months and then it'll start to
cool off again well
slowly cool off it'll still be warm in
December
that's Florida man is [__] eternal
Summer
yeah
we even have a specialty license plate
that says that it's for it has like a
little silhouette of a guy with a
surfboard and it's like supposed to be a
beach and I'm like they say Endless
Summer like it's a good thing
they're like we can go surfing all year
round yeah I don't like it
yeah you know you'll have some cold
Winters it's actually I've actually seen
it snow here but that was what 10 15
years ago
I've seen it snow here like twice in my
whole life and it wasn't even like snow
snow it was like oh look a couple flakes
which stuck it's stuck though
kind of I mean every now and then every
now and then but it's like well whenever
it freezes overnight it'll usually just
be one night like and usually it's in
January February and everybody flips out
because like it'll kill all the oranges
you know what I mean yeah because
oranges are very very sensitive to gold
and it really only has to go under like
freezing a little bit and they'll die do
we have anything any shout outs or
anything that we have to do I don't
think so all right today's show is going
to be about flat earthers and uh we I
saw a documentary on it with Jen Jen's
been studying up on it
I only people I've ever known that were
flat earthers were trolling they were
just [__] around they didn't really
believe it
but this uh there evidently is a group
of people that actually believes this
so I was watching them watching how they
operate
and uh psychoanalyzing them and uh I
know what it is I know yeah I mean I
kind of do too because it's like I was
never real versed in the Flat Earth
thing because the flat earther thing I
mean I know that there's been flat
earthers since I you know I kind of feel
like it was a thing for a while like in
the 19th century but then it kind of
fizzled out thank you Victor give me a
shout out okay what's up Vic we're
shouting you out Victor yes don't let
them make you gay
the flat earthers made him gay Flat
Earth was made you gay this time yeah
blame them Victor is gay therefore the
Earth is flat yeah
um means it's true that I mean that's
pretty much the that's that's pretty
much what their argument's about too to
be honest with you but um but so I
didn't know like a lot about that
because like I said so it kind of
fizzled out like it was kind of a thing
in the 19th it's like not a huge thing
but it was kind of like a bit of a thing
for a minute and then it kind of fizzled
out and then it kind of came back a
couple years ago
um for some reason and now it's kind
it's not massive
um from I was watching like a National
Geographic thing about it and they said
that just according to you know various
polls and things like that about two
percent of the American population all
know about the world uh two percent of
the American population believe that the
world is flat which doesn't sound like a
lot but that's about 6.5 million people
uh which is it should be zero people
um but apparently here we are no so um
so yeah so I didn't know a great deal
about that how ever a few years back
um and we probably should do a show
about this too because I'm a lot more
versed in this but um I got real into
like the whole uh creationism thing
because if you remember like back in the
90s and 2000s there was like this
concerted push to try to get creationism
or what they called intelligent design
um taught in public schools alongside
Evolution so I kind of got interested in
that then and I recognized a lot of the
same
things
um that flat earthers do and say that
creationists do and say it's very very
similar it's a very similar mindset they
use very similar arguments just in
different Sciences
um but they they and they justify their
beliefs in pretty much the same way it's
the same personality types it's yeah
yeah yeah
um because and another thing too I was
reading like there was there's all kind
of articles about this like there was
one in Scientific American there was
like I said there was a National
Geographic one like I read all the kind
of it was one of the New Yorker that was
really good that was really long and
that you know people have tried to kind
of like figure out where they were
coming from but I I just kind of feel
like it's the same kind of thing as
creationists in that some people
um seem very uncomfortable that the
world
um is maybe more complicated than there
or more random than they're comfortable
with and so they always need for there
to be they kind of want to be the center
of things and it's weird because we were
watching this documentary and it's on 2B
you can watch it for free it's called
behind the curve I think it was made for
Netflix originally back in 2018 but
um Netflix doesn't happen anymore but 2B
has it so we were watching that last
night
and some of the people on there because
they went to like a convention and all
this other stuff and they were
interviewing people some of the people
said this guy and I don't know if they
knew that they were saying you know
saying this outright but they were
basically saying that it made them feel
special you know what I mean and some of
them used like almost those exact words
yeah
um so I don't think that evidence is
really going to sweat well I know that
evidence is not going to sway them
because it doesn't they believe this
because they want to believe this yeah
even if even if and I think I think a
lot of them know that it isn't true
because people are not a
man maybe we ought to get more into what
they're saying before I start getting
down to the meaning of all this [__]
Consciousness is a strange thing it's
it's faceted you're not one person
really
you're the conscious self and then a
bunch of other
subroutines in your unconscious there's
a big
you know when you can take a person and
split the corpus callosum in between the
right and the left hemispheres their
brains
and you'll find that the right
hemisphere will say yes to a question
then the left hemisphere will say no to
that same question there's a lot of
disagreements happening inside there
it's like a committee
it's just the waking consciousness and a
couple of the other ones that are in the
unconscious that want to believe in Flat
Earth stuff the other parts in there no
it's [__] but it serves the whole so
they've chosen to believe it
and it's for social reasons and
personality types not all these people
are normal some of the ones that they
showed
in this documentary as soon as I saw him
just
their body language and their their tone
they were lunatics this one dude is a
lunatic yeah I can't remember that
dude's name but yeah he was clearly had
something he would be a lunatic no
matter what he believed it's not like
he's a lunatic Because he believes in
Flat Earth they do to be a lunatic no
matter what he believed in because he
just happens to believe in the Flat
Earth [__]
so not all these people are
I don't want to say normal let's just
say
these people are all believing in this
stuff for a reason it's very culty like
a cult
it's like Scientology and other stuff
it's almost like a coping mechanism it
gives them an identity I think
and um gives them a special
Community they can hang out with and
they can uh group up together against a
common Foe and have status inside the
group and have social interactions
well yeah that's the thing and I think
this is true of not just flat earthers
but I think it's it's true of like a lot
of these kind of like conspiracy
theory-minded sort of people that like I
said they like to feel like they're
special and what and there's nothing
inherently wrong with wanting to feel
special or unique or something like that
that's a very human proclivity like
everybody feels like that to a greater
or lesser degree so I'm not saying
there's anything really wrong with that
it's just that the way that they choose
to feel special is by having some quote
unquote secret knowledge it's like I'm
gonna I'm the person that is figured out
something that thousands and thousands
of years and like millions and millions
of people have like looked into and they
say this but it's like I'm the person
that figured out that it was all wrong
which is very very unlikely before you
have done scientific right
um experiments that have disproved what
you believe in
and these guys will get a pretty common
um scientific instrument they say well
I've got this now I got this special
thing I'm going to show you that the
Earth is not moving and then he goes to
do the experiment and it reads that no
the Earth's moving
and he goes well there's got to be
something wrong because he's trying to
prove something he already believes in
he's not just following the evidence
from his ex right which is exactly the
opposite of how science Works science
Works where you're supposed to have
evidence and it's like you come to a
conclusion but they come to the
conclusion first the conclusion being
the Earth is flat and then they try to
prove that which is not the way you're
supposed to do things and it's funny
because the behind the curve um
documentary uh yeah there were two
instances where there was two different
guys and one of the guys
um he's like so we got this it was a
twenty thousand dollar uh what was it it
was like a gyroscope like a gyroscope
like a laser gyroscope like a really
really fancy one is super super accurate
yeah and he's like so one so somebody
bought this and this is going to prove
that the Earth is flat because it's like
oh because everybody says oh the
gyroscopes has like a five degree drift
or something like that because of the
rotation of the earth and I'm like well
yeah everybody knows that they correct
for that it's just like you know that's
the reason [__] GPS Works satellites
work all that kind of stuff we correct
for that kind of stuff we know that the
Earth is moving so he so they do it he
uses it he does the experiment which
okay fair play to him and he's like yeah
it was a five percent drift I'm like
what did you think was going to happen
that's what everybody you think that you
like that everybody else that has done
the same thing didn't come up with that
result it's like but you somehow you
bought one thing yeah because you're
special right and you were gonna get a
different result that just blew the lid
off everything and like thousands of
years of scientific yeah uh you know uh
knowledge I'm just like I'm that's not
gonna happen bro and but then it's like
because it failed they always have to
come and creationists do this too it's
like you always have to like come up
with some reason why oh it doesn't work
right or we didn't do it right or
something like that they always have to
come up with some excuse right why they
didn't get the result that they wanted
and then like at the end of the
documentary there was like this
different guy and he had this like real
happy I mean they spend a lot of money
on this they are very invested and I'm
not really sure why because that's what
we were saying because Tom's like I'm
understand like why this is so important
to them I'm like yeah why is this the
hill that they chose to die yeah it's
just like their whole life is yeah I
don't really understand it like it seems
which that already tells me that this is
something psychological yeah um
this is not to attack and ridicule these
people that believe this
that's not my intent because it's not
productive really
um
there's some people are trying to change
these people's beliefs you're not going
to be able to because it's not in most
cases no because they didn't reason
themselves into those positions so a lot
of times you can't reason them out yeah
this is an emotional thing and this is
what they've chosen to do and it get
it's rewarding to them and if you start
ridiculing them that that group will
just down pull together tighter yeah
they just stick their heels a lot of
people do that and they'll and they'll
just [__] triple down and quadruple
down on this belief
so you know there have been
you know you can it's easy to poke and
tease and make fun of people you know
I'd do it uh but this particular group
isn't special there's a lot of other
groups that do this this is it's just
part of human nature you know
um some people are uh dig their heels in
over stuff that's not as crazy as this
but then there's a then there's some
groups that's even crazier and and
there's more of them Scientology is
[__] crazy if you actually know what
they really believe there's more of them
I believe
um yeah probably oh yeah yeah I'm not
sure I would I would imagine that
there's more Scientology
some of the world's major religions you
know believe in some crazy ass [__] and
there's [__] billions of them okay
um yeah it's all on a spectrum yeah now
at the heart of this [__]
thing this this Flat Earth [__]
culture that's what it is it's like it's
like a culture it's like a subculture
sure yeah um
is that they think that the world has
con that the rulers of the earth
basically and all the industries know
that they're at this flat and they are
making sure you believe that it's round
to serve them for whatever which that's
[__] really reaching if the Earth was
flat they wouldn't waste all that money
trying to tell you that it was round
yeah like do you know how much money
that would cost yeah they're faking the
space shots and faking pitchers and
they're [__] and to what purpose
satellites up with balloons and [__] you
know yeah it's a well one guy like one
guy that was on the documentary he
thought that they were faking it I mean
he didn't say he kind of said this
obliquely but um he thought that they
were all faking it because because a lot
of them and this you see the same thing
with Biblical uh creationism is that a
lot of the uh a lot of it is biblical
now the weird thing about it though is
that some people in the Flat Earth thing
they seem to come at it from a secular
standpoint but to me that seems kind of
like the whole creationist like oh no
we're intelligent design yeah you know
we're not saying it's the Christian God
we're saying we're saying we can
scientifically prove that Evolution
isn't real so I kind of feel like that's
a similar thing that's happening with
the flat earthers is that you know even
the ones that don't overtly say that
they believe the World is Flat because
that's what the Bible says
um because it well kind of it does kind
of say that but it describes a flatter
right yeah it doesn't come out and say
Hey The World is Flat might drop you
know what I mean it's yeah it kind of
describes it like that so so I do kind
of feel like even
like I said even if they don't even if
they're not like fundamentalists say
like fundamentals Christians or whatever
that would believe that because they
think the Bible is inerrant they are
using a lot of the same arguments yeah
and they're used and they're using a lot
of the same arguments that creationists
use where it's like you know humans want
to be special you know humans are
special creation we are you know what I
mean we weren't
um we're not just from and I was
watching like a National Geographic
thing like I said prior to doing the
show and there was the woman was like
interviewing like all of these people at
this Flat Earth convention or get
together or whatever and one girl said
that like she didn't say it was like oh
I you know studied the evidence and I
came to the conclusion that the Earth is
flat or whatever she said
um you know humans are special we're not
just monkeys on a ball flying through
space so it's very important to them
yeah that humans be like the center of
the universe yeah it's when you when you
when you see him and listen to them they
don't come off as religious or jesusy no
they don't but it's obvious that they're
all from a Christian back
judeo-christian backgrounds that that
that's that's the culture they're coming
from
and in a way this is kind of like a
subliminal
Christian
uh what would be a good way virtue
signal it's like a subliminal Christian
virtue signal yeah they're subliminally
saying that the Bible was true right and
that this is without coming out but
they're only focusing on the flat [__]
and then they break up into
different factions
some of the factions believe in the
fundament well that's right out of the
Bible yes another one's done the
fundament is the solid Dome it's like a
dome of the sky that has all this it has
the stars in it some of them believe
that other ones don't and they're
fighting each other basically yeah
there's like several different factions
which is fascinating not all like some
of them believe about in the disc some
of them believe there's a dome some of
them not some of them believe in an
infinite plane yeah which that blows my
mind I'm like well what wait a minute I
have so many questions like well what's
under there well even if it's a flat
Earth what's under there having a
Christian background as a kid and
everything knowing the Bible
I instantly knew what they were talking
about
Christian history is filled with um
uh religious factions fighting each
other yeah if you read the Pauline
Epistles and some of them are forgeries
and some of them are real you know even
when the canonized ones there's some a
couple of them are forgeries I remember
correctly but uh
uh the Pauline Epistles are nothing but
just Paul
just looking running [__] running a
diatribe on how to recognize Heretics
okay
a heretic is not a non-believer a
heretic is someone who believes what you
believe in but is disobeying something
or flipping something or believe
something slightly different that you
don't like right and what and it's
because during the time of Paul
Christianity was basically a bunch of
little religions all fighting for
dominance their version of he's talking
about our savior as opposed to their
savior our supper as opposed to their
supper yeah there's all and then those
humans are [__] yeah
so um homo [__] again yeah yeah so you
should be called as soon as they start
talking about hey they're an anti you
know anti-fucking
um uh
fund anti-fundament Believers and
[__] weird and I go wait hold on
they're calling each other Heretics this
is religion yeah it is this is religion
if they go about things the same way
same way the same way that creationists
do right
um you know in the way that that we have
these beliefs you know creationists we
want to prove that Evolution didn't
happen yeah Flat Earth there's one
obviously but prove that the Earth is
flat they're starting with the
conclusion and then look and they're
picking things that here's something
that is really interesting to me there's
a guy named Professor Dave I think
that's his I can't no I don't remember
if that's his YouTube channel name but
he normally does he's a scientist and he
normally does like kind of like um
educational type videos and everything
like that but I guess he started getting
[__] with by flat earthers after some
educational video he had done so he
decided to do a few videos like
debunking it or kind of like responding
to them or whatever and I was watching
one and he's super funny too so I was
watching one earlier today and it was
almost an hour long where he was
responding to Globe Busters which is one
of the
people and a really interested the two
guys like the globe I guess they have a
podcast or something I'm not going to
listen to that I've you don't need to
kill any more brain cells but um you
know what I mean I have a hard time like
doing the shows but it's interesting to
me but it's like I can't listen to
stupid people for that long it just
drives me crazy so the weird thing is is
that they're not stupid it takes a lot
of intelligence to just try to [__]
I'm just the earth flat I'm just using
that as like a shorthand and a lot of
them aren't stupid they're crazy which
is really sad dumb they're crazy I mean
if they were really could like you know
take all that energy and put it
somewhere productive they might actually
get somewhere it's easier the Earth is
much easier to explain as a sphere well
yeah and I would explain it as a [__]
flat pancake how do you explain the
motion of the sun I'm gonna get in again
nothing would make any sense that's what
I'm saying okay so you have to really do
backflips and still your mom model
doesn't work now of a flatter it it does
because it can't work because it's not
[__] flat and the Greeks knew it
four thousand years like I said this was
the guy did like an hour-long video and
it was a response to the globe Buster so
he had like um like edited in like some
of the stuff they had said like in their
video to him or whatever the two guys
from globos I can't remember what their
names were but the two guys from Globe
Busters one they seemed like they just
the way that they came across this is
there it's like two guys are like
dunning-kruger made flesh because it was
like here were two guys who obviously
had no [__] clue what they were
talking about and yet their tone of
voice was just like so smug and like so
condescending they're talking to a
scientist and telling him that he
doesn't know anything about science oh
oh we don't know anything about science
okay Dave like that he would they were
talking like that and then they would
say like the most stupid ludicrous [__]
[__] and I'm just like oh my god what
the [__] is even your problem and one
interesting thing to me was like right
near the end of the video
um the professor said he's like he and
I'm paraphrasing because I can't
remember exactly the terminology he used
but he's like basically he's like I
can't like if you just offer me like if
you just offer me like individual proofs
of like all these little separate things
he's like that's not science and like so
he said it better than I said it but you
know you get the gist and like it was
really
um interesting to me that like the
glowbusters are like what yeah and I was
like he means that you don't have a
model
the the globe Earth is a model it
explains everything that we see even the
phases of the moon is can be explained
but it makes more sense and you guys
don't have that he's like that's what
I'm telling you he's like he's like
every time yeah he's like you don't have
a model that explains a bunch of things
that explains a bunch of observations
he's like what you have is you just try
to like debunk or pick away like
separate little things but it doesn't
all go together it has one thing that he
pointed out he's like that he's like so
I said it's like oh well how do the
seasons work how how is night and day
work you know with because I don't know
if you know but they say it's like oh
the Earth is flat and then the sun and
the moon are just kind of going around
and around like that like yeah however
and they can't even agree on like how
high up it is and if you were to make a
table a model and have a son how bright
would it have to be how far above the
table would it have to be and how would
it have to move to explain the night
side and the day times daytime side and
all the 24 hours of the [__]
of the of the day system that we use
where would that sun be how would it
have to
if it was flat it couldn't be day and
night
uniformly well that's what he was saying
it would be all out of whack how would
the sun move over it
because it couldn't go in One Direction
if it went in One Direction it couldn't
come up over the other Horizon so it had
to come back or it would just let it go
around but it's like if it just went
around you would be able to see it 24
hours a day right unless it was real low
but then it wouldn't light up it
wouldn't have the in other words the the
Meridian between the night side and the
dark side wouldn't basically be a
straight line across the poles right one
pole and that was one of the arguments
he was making a different shape so it
would be light or dark randomly I guess
no matter where you were on the ground
like seven o'clock would be daytime 7 PM
would be daytime or 7 A.M would be
daytime in one place and then right
across from it it would be night you
know what I mean at [__] uh 10 a.m or
something you know it would just be
crazy it wouldn't make any [__] sense
it'd be like taking a flashlight and
shining it on a map and trying to move
it around and make the time make sense
it would it wouldn't work that's what I
mean it does it
um it doesn't jive with observation no
like and very obviously doesn't and he's
like and here's the thing it's like so
he's like so I you know made these is
like you know please explain the seasons
in your model please explain how night
and day works in your model like he
asked them so he's like interestingly
they sent me two separate videos one
explaining night and day which was
[__] and another one explaining the
seasons which was also [__] but he's
like interestingly you can't put these
two models together and make them work
and explain all of it yeah at the same
time this Flat Earth model is ancient
Egyptian the ancient Egyptians believed
this and it and uh
the judaic religion inherited it and
probably most people in Mesopotamia
maybe six seven eight thousand years ago
believe this
even believed in the duat which is the
Horizon the place where the Horizon was
they believed in an underworld and the
sun would go down into the underworld
and bring light to the Damned they were
in hell and then they would come up
through the other side gee thanks and
that there was the Waters of the
nighttime sky and sailing across it were
Gods that's where the stars were you
know that was the first thing and the
sun was a God in a chariot basically or
you know depending on what religion it
was that's the sun would go across the
uh the sky and warm everything this is
an ancient Egyptian model all right and
I don't even know if ancient Egyptian
scientists believed that it was just I
doubt it it was just a religious Tale
and it's like metaphorical you know well
no I think they believed it I think they
inherited that model
I don't think scientists in ancient
Egypt believed it uh but common people
and religious people did most people
were religious then
now
there's a lot of problem with the with
that model
the Achilles heel to the Flat Earth
model is if it's a flat Earth and
there's a dome above it what is the
Earth's sitting on
the Bible says it sits on Pillars of the
Earth so in other words table legs it's
a it's a table with legs for sitting on
a table but what are those legs standing
on who's under the table yeah
what are the legs standing on is the dog
under the table yeah
yeah that's so there's a big problem
with that
they've never they've never answered
what are the pillars resting on
well that's the thing I think even in
modern Flat Earth I'm not even it's I'm
not gonna tell a theory because it's not
it's not a theory no it's a faith it's
absolutely not
um the flatter thing I think it's funny
because I saw a couple of um videos
about it and I guess because I don't
know if you know but flat earthers call
uh people that actually believe in
reality as Globes or globetards yeah
Globe Tarts and we're Globe tart that's
nice it's [__] hilarious but I do
like that and I had never heard this
term before but I do like that people
that believe in reality actually call
Flat earthers flarfs which I thought was
kind of cute it's just any other thing
that's war of words if you make fun of
them they'll just do the same thing back
and that's what they're doing they're
calling us Globe Tarts I like that one
that's good though but you know I'm
ex-army and [__] I mean it's not real
creative I gotta say it's just yeah I
mean I understand fighting and [__]
and and fat mouthing fat mouthing is
just fighting with words it's not
confined to logic it just has to be
effective insults and glove tart is a
good one that's [__] hilarious even
like I said like even though it's not
effective I know they're [__] with me
it's not creative because it's like well
because they use that well you know like
people got like libtard they say that
all the time so it's just like another
thing right so it's just kind of like
I'm like eh you could have thought of
something better than that probably but
you know and I'm not offended yeah so um
because it's dumb but uh but yeah so
that so that's the thing and it when we
were talking earlier about you know them
fighting and everything like that the
documentary it's fascinating like I said
seriously watch it it's really it's
fascinating but yeah there's like at
least was there like at least three
different factions going on there there
was the crazy guy whose name I can't
remember and he was the one that claimed
he started this whole thing because he's
one of those and he's just like on there
like ranting and [__] like that like on
his YouTube videos and it's like they
can't even agree so like they have the
the main guy that was on there that they
followed through most of the thing was
Mark Sargent who was kind of like one of
the big guys in Flat Earth III and they
were doing they have conventions for
this now so they were doing a convention
and this was 2018 so I guess the or 2017
when they made the documentary and so
like it was in Raleigh and um so so
they're doing it and it's like so the
the crazy guy I wish I could remember
what his name was what the [__] was that
dude's name I can't think what his name
was but the crazy guy was saying that
um that all of the people that he was
telling people not to go to the
convention because they were all shills
yeah uh so there so now they're calling
each other shells and he's like the Flat
Earth Society is all like government so
he thinks that everyone else is paid by
the government or by Warner Brothers for
some reason
um because it got merged with the
government World War II is what is right
yeah or something like the funny thing
about that I couldn't follow all the
funny thing about them is that is that
the the leaders of their little Society
are intelligent they're just kind of
crazy all right they they have dedicated
did themselves to believing this
and it's a virtue signal if you ask me
it's a virtues and it gives them a
society and a scene to hang out with and
it gives them an identity and clout and
pull over members like a cult it's a
religion it is it's very culty it's a
religion okay
um
I think some of them are True Believers
I think a lot of them are only like yeah
they just having fun I think they're
just going along with it because all
their friends are doing it I think some
people just like to be contrary yeah
yeah that's nothing it's just to say no
oh no no no no no no I'm like that too
so yeah I know you are a lot of the
things in in this I could identify with
the human element behind right this is
very much human nature everybody does
what they're doing just not like this
and not not to the subject and not and
not in this subject they're very
strong-willed
um and pig-headed
because this is the reality they want to
believe in whether it's true or not
that's something that takes a lot of
will even if it's a lie they're gonna
believe it
and they will go through all kinds of
crazy mental nutritions right to hang on
to that which is like why would you do
that and like I said especially over
something which seems It's religious
relatively in you know in like it's not
really that important to your day-to-day
life it's religious really whether the
Earth is flat or round it's a religion
whether it's Christianity or not it has
this is a certain aspect it kind of
comes from religion that they've turned
into a unique religion that stands on
its own yeah fighting about whether the
Earth is flat around has become a
religion because when you listen to them
they don't really talk about Jesus or
anything but that's where this idea came
from yeah it's a religious idea it's a
religious idea that has become a
religion of its own well it's okay I'm
gonna and this is kind of jumping off
from that it's a religious idea but the
modern Flat Earth movement which came
from uh quote unquote static astronomy
came from religion but also as a side
note
um the fact that it sort of kind of came
out at a time when science was making a
lot of progress and I think a lot of
people and you see this in creationism
too like when Darwin came out with
Origin of Species and all that kind of
stuff there was a subset of people that
were very uncomfortable with the stuff
that science was discovering and so they
wanted to go back to a simpler time and
in zetetic astronomy which was kind of
like the Bible of this movement or at
least the modern movement
it even says stuff like we need to go
back to the old days where you know
reality is just what your senses tell
you it is because shit's getting too
complicated we don't understand this
math we don't understand the physics we
don't understand any of that and we
think that reality is just what you can
see what you can feel what you can touch
your own personal experience you have to
touch it you have to so it was almost
like people feeling threatened by how
complicated things were getting how you
know complicated knowledge was getting
how complicated scientific like
technology was getting that's what
they're doing and they wanted to hearken
back to like well and a couple of the
people in the documentary and I've seen
like a couple other documentaries about
this where people said this very thing
you don't need math right you can see it
everybody just wants it to be and [__]
this freaks me out a little bit like the
woman that was on the documentary who's
kind of another big I guess she has like
a a podcast or something yeah they
attack her too because she's pretty you
know yeah and her name's Patricia Steele
yeah we'll get into that Patricia steer
I think her name is yeah she is cute
she's a nice one yeah she she yeah she
seems like a nice lady but she's batshit
crazy but Apple I don't know if I'd say
batshit crazy but she has like some
weird ideas I'm gonna say she has chosen
consciously right to believe in
something that she probably doesn't
really actually believe she said I don't
think she actually on the documentary
that she trusts no one except herself
and she used for an example she said
because the Boston bombing had happened
not like too long prior and she said if
an event like the Boston bombing
happened again I would not believe it
until I would unless I was there and had
my own leg blown off that's what she
said
so I was just like so now we've gotten
to a point where you have to experience
something otherwise everything is fake
and that is a very that is mind-blowing
to me that somebody would be like that
because it's like nobody in the world
can experience every single thing and
the the crazy thing about this and I was
thinking about this earlier because
you know the flat earthers they think
that the Earth is flat and that all
around the outside like the edge of the
disc or whatever is like a hundred what
is 150 foot ice wall or something that's
what we think of as like Antarctica and
like a bunch of the Flat Earth videos
because I did watch some of them until
like I said my brain cells started like
jumping out my ears like stop it Jenny
so it's like so I had to stop but that
so some of them say with absolute
seriousness this is why you're not
allowed to go to Antarctica like there
are people there with guns and they'll
turn you away I said oh except for all
the Antarctic cruises yeah that people
go on like every [__] day yeah lots
of people go there Melissa McHenry went
yeah we know people that went there yeah
it's you got pictures of yourself you
can go bikini fine jump into that ice
cold water
um
yeah swimming from one boat to the next
right off the coast of [__]
Antarctica gotta watch it crazy you'll
have like [__] heart failure but the
uh she jumped in ice cold water yeah um
they do cruises though yeah you can go
so No One's Gonna shut up part of this
[__] has to do with politics too me and
Jan have very different viewpoints in it
but but almost on everything we agree
when we actually when we're running
around living normal life when something
happens we're like well [__] that our
reactions are exactly the same but the
US is becoming and most of the [__]
Western Civilization has become
extremely polarized
and what happened to these people if you
ask me
is they're uh they're basically
Christian type people
who are I would say they are right wing
and they have I think they have rejected
anything that is left-wing
erroneously because both sides have good
ideas it's just that it's now become
polarized well universities in the news
are basically owned by uh left people
you know you go to a university it's all
left-wing people same thing with all
your news even CNN or even uh we're not
CNN uh even Fox
the people behind the scenes and
everything and all those people are
mostly Democrats
so what they've done is is they they're
going to say I don't believe anything
Democrats say
and they're gonna [__] dig in there
the Earth is flat
that's part of what they're doing and
what you said that woman says if I if it
if I don't get blown up no matter what I
see I don't believe it it's a total
rejection of Democrats that's part of
the thing which is I think which is
Extreme which is an extreme Tad it's
well that well you got people are
Democrats or total rejection of anybody
who is a Republican or something like
that so there's extreme
hatred on both sides given
given ultimate power to either side
they'll kill the other side off I
predicted this a long time ago
if the if you give them the power once I
will kill off the other
so they just hate each other and this is
factoring into this
they're not going to believe anything
coming out of a university
nope that's Democrats well like I said
they don't believe I you know yeah I
think that is that is yeah aspect of it
I hate to bring that up on the show I
want to bring people no but they got
people out here if you're a Democrat
there are people that hate you
also if you're a republican on the right
there are Democrats that hate you not
all of them but they got them out there
they would kill you if they could you
both sides would
I wouldn't kill anybody unless they were
a cigarette but me and you kind of don't
really give a [__] we don't really fit
in we don't really care what these
people do anyway yeah not really I mean
I have to care they're gonna go to a
Hell in a handbag to the extent that I
just watch when it affects my [__]
yeah yeah I watch my own back take care
of people that I know and care about but
everybody else y'all keep to your
goddamn self y'all gonna kill each other
well that's the thing and it's like I
was watching something like Neil
deGrasse Tyson was saying he's like you
know if you just want to believe the
Earth is flat fine he's like I don't
give a [__] about that but he's like if
on the other hand you believe the Earth
is flat and you start trying to like
pass laws based on that to like you know
that are gonna affect other people then
we have a problem well yeah but he was
getting to the point that you know no
one cares what you believe yeah until it
starts affecting other people's lives
which like I said you saw the same thing
happen in the 90s and the 2000s with
creationists who were trying very hard
to like push their [__] into public
school and all this other kind of stuff
and there was a big [__] thing about
it in several States and that was a
different world though no I know and but
I'm just saying it's kind of a similar
thing and and like I said it's kind of a
similar thing most people all died off
and a lot of Boomers you have to say you
have to think too that the flat earthers
they're coming from the same mindset as
the creationists are which is a very
anti-science
um you know it's very anti-science it's
very anti-reality in a lot of ways even
though I'm sure that that's not the way
that they would put it and like I said
it's just it's very much a I almost want
to say it's like solid salasip sis
I've been drinking yeah I can't say it
either it's like when you see yourself
as the center of the world right right
so I just kind of it's this weird places
there thank you I was like I couldn't
solipsistic my tongue wouldn't um
right yeah I know getting old sucks you
guys but um but it's not no it's not
that bad not yet no it's actually a lot
better not not yet anyway we'll we'll
see in 20 30 years right but um but yeah
so it's a it's kind of a point of view
where
you know you are the most important
person in the universe so if you have to
see it's like oh well if it doesn't
happen to me then it doesn't happen kind
of thing which is
that is crazy to me that is a crazy
point of you to have there are billions
of other people on this Earth that are
just as convinced that they're the
center of the universe as you are and
they are all wrong nobody is it's like
we're all on here we all have to like
work together to some extent you know
it's it's all like a big system and [__]
like that nobody's centered there's
nobody no one person that's another
thing too it's like again I think it's
like a very narcissistic thing because
like I said with that guy on the
documentary that's like I'm gonna spend
20 000 well I don't think he bought it
but I'm gonna spend twenty thousand
dollars on this gyroscope and it's gonna
upend thousands of years of accumulated
scientific knowledge one dude with one
yeah instrument that other people have
and have used successfully I'm gonna be
the one to upend the entire Paradigm no
you're not you're just not that's just
not the way the world works and I hate
to tell you that yeah yeah uh another
thing though is you notice that you
can't
you can't [__] pigeonhole
every okay all those [__] people on
the right as being flat earthers which
that's something that the left will do
uh flat earthers are [__] small no
that's a fringe of a fringe I don't
think anybody yeah believe in outer
space you know what I'm talking about
they you know they know that the Earth
is round they want spaceships and [__]
like spaces and it's not just these
dudes that think of crazy [__] I worked
with black dudes that didn't believe in
outer space they thought it was
something just made up by white people
oh they don't see that [__] in the
telescopes now it's just so anybody can
believe crazy [__] well yeah it's just
that I don't know I there's not a I
don't know any of any [__] like
religious cult filled with black dudes
running around saying white people made
up outer space
that maybe uh what was the black
Israelites probably maybe they don't
believe in outer space but they're crazy
too yeah yeah I'm not sure they'll
probably say yeah white man made up
outer space that's not in the Bible
that's probably something that they
would say but yeah but that's kind of
like flatter Theory that's like
flattered Earth I mean because they
don't I don't they don't they kind of
believe in space but they don't believe
that it's the way that we know that it
is they probably think you could breathe
up there
yeah I wonder if they do they believe
they believe in The Flash Gordon space
and run out on the wings right out on
the wing of this you're getting AJ you
can just fly with your wings and [__]
like that it's like pretty you can jump
off with a parachute yeah and make it
back to Earth and it works yeah which uh
please don't do that that actually would
not work but um yeah you know what I
mean and well that's the thing too and
that's like another thing that uh this
other thing that I was watching like um
kind of pointed out is that I kind of
feel like
here's the thing
whenever and you see I used to see this
with creationists too whatever you say
to like the Flat Earth or they'll be
like oh well you know the round earthers
or the globe tards or whatever they want
to call us
you know um they say that this happens
and that happens and you know explain
that and so like a scientists are like
okay I'll explain it and they explain it
to them and then they're just like oh
fake or they don't because they don't
understand it is why I don't think I I
no I think they do understand it well
some stuff they don't I think some stuff
I think mostly you violated their faith
yeah uh faith has a lot to do with it
even though they don't it may not be the
Christian faith it's their own faith and
that faith is based on the Christian
faith but it's Faith
um
and they're not alone a lot of the
world's like this Islam is huge and
Islam believes stuff doesn't believe in
evolution uh
friend of mine Assad who lives in Saudi
Arabia he's gone through medical school
he doesn't believe in he doesn't believe
in evolution
and uh I was trying to talk with him
about it no because you're you're fine
you're dealing with Islam
all right which uh okay you know I
understand I understand how religions
work you're you're fighting somebody's
cultural identity you don't want to do
that you know yeah dig in
and uh yeah because well because he's
attacking there you're attacking their
personhood in a lot of ways yeah which I
get that and that can't have deadly
results literally
yeah because some people will just kill
you
I just that's not a good thing for you
and it might be a good thing for them if
they kill you so but that was the world
I came from you know being having a
military background living all over the
world you got to be careful when you go
to another other countries that's their
country
and um you're a guest there and there's
an old saying that the West used to
believe in but not anymore it's so
Imperial now it used to be When in Rome
you do as the Romans that was the saying
well when you're when I went to the
Middle East oh man no I was as Middle
Eastern as possible
and they're nice people but they have
their own cultural references they grew
up in an entirely different culture than
you right if you're some girl and you
decide to [__] take your shirt off in
public there's gonna be serious trouble
okay it's not that's not the West
so
it's just the way it is
you know they're it's a totally
different culture well it's kind of like
the same thing with these dudes
yeah you can't reason with them yeah
they have their
their minds are made up this is what
they want to believe in this is their
identity and they'll probably fight to
protect it but there isn't enough of
them to make any difference to normal
people like us Flat Earth dudes don't
[__] with me come on not yet anyway they
probably will after this video no
no because I'll I'll actually just talk
about Flat Earth reality with them
because I you know I can say anything I
want so oh yeah it's flat it's flat I
know it's flat because I can see that
it's flat
that's pretty much the entirety of their
argument you need to be honest yeah yeah
look at that that's the first thing they
always say is like look at the Horizon
it looks flat therefore the Earth is
flat the satellites are being held up by
balloons it's not yeah some of them say
that yeah it's not I mean they don't all
say the same thing because like I said
there are several factions yeah there's
there's disagreement over how high the
ice wall is around the disc there's
disagreement over whether there's a dome
over the [__] or not that has there's
disagreement over how high the moon and
the sun are
there's disagreement over whether the
moon and the sun are actually spheres
are also discs there's too many problems
with the model
if it's flat it has to have an edge
you'd fall off the edge
okay even Sailors in the even semen in
the 14 1500s new
there was no Edge they knew the [__]
[__] was around yeah this thing that
they thought they were gonna go they
were [__] with you that's a myth they
knew that it was round that came that
was the Protestants did that later yeah
that was an ant that was anti-catholic
propaganda if there's an ice wall
you'd run you'd find it you'd have
pictures of it you'd be able to get into
a boat and find it you'd be able to get
an airplane to find it if it's forever
then that means you could go forever in
One Direction and find another planet
with aliens on it we haven't had that
either we haven't been invaded by
long-range bombers from another creation
another type of human being they haven't
been attacked by them you know
because if it was endless then that
means it's endless endless means
in in Infinity yeah so that means an
Infinity of possibilities and
probabilities in an infinite distance
away that's [__] far
so God's just going to make it infinite
but they're just going to put humans in
this one little spot the rest of it's
all wasted space you're basically
talking about outer space that means
there'd be aliens over there yeah
no I'm sure probably some of them
deposit none of those models there's all
kind of crazy
you go ahead and talk about flattering
[Laughter]
but yeah oh well one of the things that
I started to say like before but
um I didn't get to it was that there
okay so in the documentary there was
like a um there was the whole gyroscope
experiment which failed obviously and
then there was a different guy like a
different set of guys
that were doing another experiment and
they had like this high-powered laser
and their idea was they were going to
they have like these boards that had
holes cut in them and they said okay
well the Earth is flat which they were
trying to prove then we'll put these
boards I can't remember it was set like
several miles apart like over a bottle
of body of water and he's like well
obviously the laser should shoot like
straight through the holes because the
holes were all at the same height
well spoiler alert that is not what
happened because the Earth is [__]
curved and all they said like he's
looking at the very obviously that the
laser is not going through the hole and
it's kind of going like that it's like
not coming out of the hole and all he
says is he just like looks at and goes
interesting
did it make him change his mind probably
not yeah well that's the thing it's like
the whole thing about the dude with the
gyroscope with the five degree drift
which like I said was what everybody
said was gonna happen there's a five
degree drift because the rotation of the
earth and he's like no I'm going to
prove that it's not and then it's like
and then they showed him like at a meet
up of other flat earthers and he's like
yeah we need to you know we did that
experiment and then we don't know why it
failed so we need to get that going so
that'll be like one of our proofs that
we can present at the convention which
is what they were doing and I'm just
like did it ever occur to you that it
failed because you're wrong I mean
that's the whole point of doing an
experiment you're like I said they think
they're being scientific by doing these
experiments but if they get a result
that they didn't want then they just
pause it oh well there's something the
matter with the experiment like we did
it wrong because they didn't get the the
outcome that they expected they got the
globular outcome and that made them bad
so there must be some reason why other
than the simplest reason which is that
the Earth is a [__] sphere and it's
just it makes me really mad it's just
very frustrating for me like these kind
of people because you can't like I said
and I know
um and actually I was watching like I
said Neil deGrasse Tyson was talking
about this too and I and I used to get
into when I was into like the Evolution
versus creationism thing there was like
a big debate in the scientific Community
it's like well should we even debate
these people because a lot of times like
you know creationists and stuff would
like add like they're like oh well we
want to debate like this paleontologist
or whatever biologist and a lot of the
scientists like well should we it's like
on the one hand it's like you know we
might be you know giving information to
people that might be on the fence and
like they might learn something and
something like that but then on the
other hand we're legitimizing a stupid
point of view so it's like so some of
them came down on one side and someone
came out on the other side and Neil
deGrasse Tyson was like look if I'm he's
like something like this he's like
something like Flat Earth or Evolution
or something like that he's like I don't
think that that should be debated it's
like it's settled
um he's like we can debate other things
like that aren't settled like political
matters or whatever that like people
have different ideas about but you know
there are still legitimate ideas he's
like but [__] like the Earth is round
he's like that's a settle that was
settled like thousands of years ago that
is not something that should be debated
because it's just giving legitimacy to a
stupid point of view I gotta uh correct
Victor Garcia though Victor Victor
Garcia said the Dixiecrats ended up
becoming the southern Republicans No Lie
it didn't happen the Dixiecrats died out
that was a generation that would be like
my granddad's dinner generation
uh
not even my dad's generation the
Dixiecrats died out
um the southern Republicans were always
Southern Republicans they're exactly the
way it is Elvis was a southern
Republican
um James Brown was a was a southern
Republican the Dixiecrats had nothing to
do with Republicans they were very
different Dixiecrats hated Elvis Presley
they hated rock and roll
the Dixiecrats were KKK especially in
Mississippi where my family's from
they didn't flip anything it's just that
the Dixie Crest died
they got old and died
that's where you Foghorn Leghorn cracker
types
yes they died away and we were replaced
okay so now I got like uh yeah okay but
whatever that didn't have anything to do
with anything
um all right
so let's go back to like I said this has
been a settled
thing
and here's the thing too
flat earthers a lot of them are very
into this whole you know I I see it as
flat therefore it is flat like they'll
do quote unquote experiment like
[__] experiments and stuff like that
but like I said if the outcome of the
experiment is not what they want then
they'll find some reason or they'll find
some stupid convoluted excuse as to why
it didn't work
but the thing about it is that relying
on observation
the ancient [__] Greeks figured out
that the Earth was a sphere thousands of
years ago by using observation they
didn't go into space they didn't have
all of the you know technological
Wizardry that we have nowadays and yet
they still figured it out and they were
correct even back I think it was like
[__] what was it the sixth Century BC
or something like that like a dude like
a Greek dude what was his name Eris Eris
Denise or orestines or something like
that he figured out the circumference of
the earth just from like poles and like
math
and he was all he was very very close I
think he said it was between 24 000 and
29 000 uh you know miles and it's 24 900
I think so he was very close and that
was like thousands of years ago so like
I said they figured it out
and the thing about it too is that even
though and I think even when I was in
elementary school you know what I mean
and they're teaching you about Columbus
and all that kind of crap
um I think that even back in the 70s and
80s they were still teaching that
Columbus
thought the world was flat and that they
that was one of the reasons for the
voyage I'm pretty sure that they did
teach that
um but that is not the case uh most
educated people in the Medieval World
also knew that the world was a globe and
like I said pretty much any
observation
you know if you think about it it's
we'll show you we'll demonstrate you the
truth of that you know what I mean the
world is not it's just not flat it's not
um so yeah so as I said now the so there
was
the the Flat Earth stuff was religious
largely like I said as soon as they had
got the observations and they knew how
to do geometry and [__] like that they
figured out the Earth was the sphere
now
the modern Flat Earth movement derives
largely
from
kind of like the 19th century
um the thing about it so this guy comes
out and his name was [__] wait a
minute I lost my thing okay his name was
Samuel rowbotham row Botham something
like that
now he did this experiment called the
Bedford level experiment there's a
Wikipedia page if you want to look it up
he did it in 1838
his idea was there was this
um Canal that was like super straight
for like six miles or something like
that and he's like well if the Earth is
really curved then
I should be able to like have a boat
with like a pole on it and you know it's
as it goes you know farther away like it
should recede and you shouldn't be able
to like see you know what I mean like a
boat will go over the curvature or the
Horizon and you can just see the bottom
of it goes away and then you just see
the math
now he did the experiment and evidently
at least according to him
um you could see it the whole six miles
so from this one experiment which did
not take into account like atmospheric
conditions or anything like that he
posited that the Earth was indeed flat
and like I said this was around the time
that you know it's very like
Enlightenment time [__] like that so
some people were very much into going
back to like the simpler days when it's
like all we knew was from just our own
senses or our gut instinct or whatever
so people wanted to go back to that
because [__] was getting too hard nobody
wanted to learn any math apparently so
that's what they did so he wrote this
whole book
uh that he called like zetetic astronomy
um which was basically that's what they
called it and that's what he was saying
it's like where
everything has to be like from your
personal experience like you have to
personally experience it you have to
personally see it otherwise it's not
real basically was what he was saying he
wrote this book called Earth not a globe
and this is basically where the modern
Flat Earth uh model if you want to call
it that it's not really comes from so
this is where the whole like flat disc
by you know with the North Pole in the
middle
and then what we think of as the
continent of Antarctica all around the
edges like a big ice wall that you can't
go past because it's like really really
high now he posited that the sun and
moon were 3 000 miles above the Earth uh
this is not
um so like because some modern ones like
think it's closer some think it's
farther away uh none of it works you
know it doesn't really matter like how
far away it is but he originally said it
was 3000 Miles and that there was a
cosmos uh 3 100 miles of the earth which
I'm assuming he means the Dome
the firmament whatever that had all the
stars and [__] stuck in it I think
that's what he's talking about and you
have to say too that he was coming at
this from again a Biblical perspective
um he did not believe in the round earth
because in his view it conflicted with
the biblical
world view and that he was not going to
have that so he was going to find proof
that the world was flat just like the
Bible said
so he basically
um he debated like some big scientists
of the day like Alfred Russell Wallace
and stuff like that and
um because like I said a lot of these
debates I don't really know how much
value there is in them especially
on a topic that is obviously true
um you know like the round earth or like
Evolution uh I don't think there's much
Point uh in doing debates because
they made their mind up well well one
they made their mind up and two
um debates are not really about truth
they're about whoever has the better
better zigger yeah
um you know what I mean it's basically
like whoever can talk better and there's
even a thing like in creationism uh
there's something called Uh there's a
guy named Dwayne Gish who was like a
creationist and he would debate
scientists sometimes and he would always
even if he didn't win he would always
claim that he won because what he would
do and there's a phrase for it too like
it's called the Gish gallop and what he
would do is he would just come out in
the debate and he would just have all of
these well what about this what about
this what about this what about this and
if you couldn't counter every single
tiny minuscule little
thing in his then he would just say that
he won you know what I mean so it's just
like he would come up with all these
like little random like [__] [__] you
know what I mean and if you couldn't
counter every single thing that he would
just claim that he won even though if
you've given time you obviously probably
could counter it you know given time and
research and stuff but it's a debate
format is not really the best
uh you know kind of framework for
discovering scientific truth I'm just
saying so I don't really know how much
value there is in that kind of stuff
but so and you know and just saying that
like this flat earther guy like uh
robotum he debated a bunch of scientists
too and I guess enough people were
swayed by his [__] that he created a
whole society the tedetic society
he had one in New York and he had one in
England as well and he would ship his
books everywhere and all that other kind
of stuff
so um interestingly Alfred Russell
Wallace who was an actual scientist
um he actually did the same the Bedford
level experiment that had convinced
robbotham that the world was flat he did
it under the scientific conditions and
indeed the world was curved uh just like
you would imagine so you know what I
mean I don't know what the [__] deal
was with the first one
so in 1877 uh there was a new book that
came out a new manual of biblical
cosmography like again so like I said
this is a religion this is coming from a
religious framework it's not scientific
in any
stretch the imagination
um and basically they're saying because
one of the most fundamental things like
any video even nowadays like any YouTube
video you watch that says you know
disproving the Flat Earth or whatever
pretty much the first argument because
you can go and see this yourself is you
know go to a lake or like a body of
water or something like that and if
there's a boat in it and it goes over
the horizon then obviously like I said
the bottom of the boat will disappear
and then like the mass will disappear
and stuff like that because it's going
over the curvature
so this is one of the first things that
the flat earthers are always try to
counter so they always try to come up
with some reason
why it looks like that because it
obviously looks like that a lot of
people have seen it you know so they'll
just say like oh well it's just um
perspective or it's atmospheric
conditions or it's a mirage or it's
something like that they always have to
come up with like some [__] excuse
you know what I mean
now after rowbotham died
there was this other lady who was in the
zetetics society
um and she was called Lady Elizabeth God
that scared the crap out of me yeah
ghost pulling [__] down no that always
falls off
um called Lady Elizabeth Blount and she
kind of carried it on she was like it
was called the universal zetetic society
that was in 1893. and uh again very
biblical very openly biblical
um the mission statement
of this group was whoa the propagation
of knowledge related to Natural
cosmogony in confirmation of the Holy
scriptures based on practical scientific
investigation so basically what they're
trying to do is they're trying to make
science fit into the Bible they're
trying to use science to prove the Bible
again very much like what the
creationists were doing uh recently
so they had a whole magazine called the
Earth not a globe review
and um it was pretty active for a while
I don't think it was huge or anything
like that but it was a thing like I said
for like a minute for like a few decades
or whatever
and but after that I kind of feel like
it's sort of
faded out some
um you know it's after the first world
war specifically
um I feel like people just kind of lost
interest and it kind of became again I'm
sure there were some Believers somewhere
but it wasn't anywhere in the beginning
in the public eye like it had been uh
prior to that you know what I mean
however for whatever reason
more recently probably starting I think
it was um
2014 2015 something like that uh Flat
Earth like searches for flat earth
started like spiking now they don't know
if it was something to do it might have
had something to do with one of the um
because Mark Sargent put out that video
about it like he got into he was one of
the guys that was on the documentary
that we watched and he put out a YouTube
video and it went viral pretty much and
the thing about it that's interesting is
that they interview like a lot of these
people at the convention to a man like
99 of them got into flatter Earth from
like a YouTube video that was
recommended to them because they were
into other conspiracy [__] so like the
YouTube algorithm got them into Flat
Earth because it's like oh hey you
believe in JFK conspiracies or you know
the Illuminati or reptilians or whatever
so hey here watch this and so like a lot
of them saw that and it seemed like it
was just all kind of snowballed
um so it was basically just like YouTube
videos that caused this bike I feel like
I don't know if that was entirely what
it was but it does seem like that was
like the search term started going up
like way after like after a couple like
big prominent videos about Flat Earth
came out like it started like really
gaining momentum which I thought was
really interesting and the thing about
it too is that and here's another and
this isn't just about Flat Earth but
like a lot of people are like this
they're because they're a whole Mantra
like especially like a lot of conspiracy
theory type people and stuff they're
always just like do your own research do
your own research I'm like Oh you mean
go and watch some [__] YouTube video
that's what they mean go watch a YouTube
video that confirms your biases that's
what that's what that means I feel like
because it's like here's the thing Mark
Sargent says and I don't know if I
believe him entirely
on the documentary he said I didn't want
to be a flat earther he started looking
into it for I don't remember why he said
what like inspired him to look into it
but he's like I he said he spent what 18
months or something like that looking
into the evidence
um which like I said is YouTube videos
looking at YouTube videos about Flat
Earth yeah and that convinced him and
he's just like oh my God there's we've
been lied to you like for thousands of
years and I'm just like okay no I'm
sorry you haven't but it's
who would do that why it's just like
that that's why like I said I know
there's and we've talked about this
before because we talked about you know
when we were talking about like MK Ultra
another so I know there's conspiracies I
know there's [__] up [__] I know
there's like I know there's smaller
conspiracies these big Global
conspiracies that would involve
essentially millions of people yeah yeah
and it can't happen that much no no no
not possible and why
right it would be that even the Germans
back in World War II was hiding the fact
that the Earth was flat they lied about
where the V2 Rockets landed because for
the V2 Rockets to land in England the
Earth would have to be cut around they
were doing a almost parabolic type shots
you know what I mean using the Earth's
gravitational pull you know what I mean
so the Nazis knew it was [__] right
that's what I mean it's like come on
here's the thing and like I said this is
the same thing that they used to come up
with with variations and stuff like that
if their arguments were true yeah then
all of the [__] we have today the
technology and stuff like that nothing
works nothing would work satellites
wouldn't work it doesn't work in their
model it just doesn't like the reason we
know that the that the Earth is a sphere
and we've we know that and so all of
this stuff works here's another thing
let's say you were to take a map of the
sphere that we use the globe and flatten
it out and then try to sail from one
position onto the globe and another
if it was flat
it would take a different amount of time
to reach that location yeah but it
consistently takes the same amount of
time it would take as if it was a sphere
yeah because when you flat it out a
bunch of [__] you know like if you
see a flat map
you're going to see big [__] empty
spaces where there's no water there
because it would you flatten the map out
if you were to cut it out you'd have to
wrap it around a a something around you
know what I mean so there's a lot of
distortions like uh Greenland isn't as
big as it shows on a flat map yeah like
that like I said distorted it's very
distorted but if you were you know so
that means that [__] just travel
would be all [__] up you wouldn't
arrive at the location
at the proper time that you would expect
you know what I mean if it was flat and
that's that's it only makes sense the
[__] only makes sense if it's a sphere
it's stupid so many things so many
things would not work yeah so many
things that we just take for granted we
have telescopes that are powerful enough
to actually image the lunar lander on
the surface of the [__] Moon
that moon is the sphere and that ladder
is there and space travel with that
rocket would not have been possible if
the Earth was flat
one sphere orbiting around another
sphere
and my granddad was involved in that
shift he worked for [__] NASA
McDonnell Douglas Grumman Aerospace and
general atomics
as well right he was an electrician got
pictures of that [__] nerdy ass [__]
with his pocket protector out in front
of the [__] rocket jet propulsion
laboratory the Rockets behind him
pocket calculator
what was those things that what they
call that thing well like a compass no
it was a round thing and you could
[__] oh I know what you're talking
about uh
this before pocket calculators
it was a mechanical calculator that they
used
they had several of them
[__] what was that [__] like a slide
rule slide rule slide rules and then
they had other things that for they had
other ones that were different that was
before that blows my mind that they like
put people in spaces with that yeah they
were using side rules Peters or anything
yeah that's hardcore drafting tables
yeah we figured that [__] out just with
paper and pencil yeah that's how awesome
we could be if we want yeah and you know
what here's something else
his name was Charles Williams that was
my granddad
he was half a Syrian Christian his
mother was an Assyrian who came running
from some kind of genocide he was
devoutly Christian
and a minister uh on his off time he was
doing a little Baptist Minister type
[__]
and was big into the Bible and
Revelations and all that kind of [__]
but he knew about outer space he was big
and he was a [__] engineer very
intelligent just because you believe in
some crazy [__] doesn't mean you're not
intelligent it was just his culture that
was just what he was into
yeah that's um [__] Isaac Newton was
a brilliant physicist right invented
physics as we know it [__] was
religious as [__] hell and believed
in alchemy yeah okay which is not a
science
so it's fascinating it's that kind of
stuff is like fascinating yeah and the
thing about it is that watching this
documentary was really enlightening
because I mean I didn't think the people
because I know that like smart people
have stupid ideas like all the time you
know what I mean it's just that's just
part of Being Human
no no smart no smart person is smart
about everything okay and everybody has
biases and blinders and various things
that they don't see about themselves
so I wouldn't call any of the people
that they interviewed in this
documentary none of them were stupid
um you know I don't think any of them
were like Geniuses or anything they're
just normal they just yeah they just
seemed average above average
intelligence and what I thought was
really interesting is that they
juxtaposed there was actually a scene
where they went because it was like a
big um there was a solar eclipse you
know during that time and you know
that's another thing that the Flat Earth
model doesn't really explain
uh our eclipses so that's kind of why
they focused on that a little bit but
some of the flat earthers were there and
they were coming up with some I don't
even remember what [__] excuse they
came up with for why they for why the
eclipse worked because obviously it
doesn't work in their model the way it
does in real life
so the thing about it is that
I don't there there was a thing at the
end so they were juxtaposing the Flat
Earth people with this big Meetup of
like scientists it was like some some
restaurant or a pub or something and
they were all just kind of drinking and
talking and hanging out or whatever and
this one guy at the end who I think was
a physicist and he went up and gave a
talk and this dude I gotta say this dude
is like a way better person than I am
because he was basically like he was
talking about the flat earthers because
it was going on at the same time like
the convention and he basically said and
I'm paraphrasing that it's like you know
it's really easy to make fun of people
like this but he's like in a lot of ways
maybe we as scientists have failed them
he's like and he's like these people
might make great scientists he's like
look at them they're very inquisitive
they're very skeptical they're very
passionate about what they believe in or
what they you know and they're
interested in it it's like if we could
just
you know show them like how to do real
science like they could really like
contribute to society someday yeah but
you know what I mean that's that's
that's a nice thing to say it's not a
reality though I understand what they're
they're trying to extend an olive branch
but yeah okay the person that said that
is a as a left-leaning person okay
they do not have a good grasp of
religious faith that type of personality
and zealotry
you can't reason with them no I know
that no
and like I said probably he knows that
too yeah but I mean we all know that we
all know they believe this because
they're there they have a certain
psychology to them where this belief
serves serves them and benefits them so
people are going to believe what
benefits them
and it benefits them in terms of the
psychologically
emotionally and socially
didn't have friends they're part of a
community that's being under attack by
an outside world they feel and everybody
loves that because you can circle the
wagons and it's very like tribalism
We're All in This Together against them
we're being attacked it's like everybody
yeah exactly that's what's happening
yeah and a lot of them will join it some
people will there are people out there
that will join that situation knowing
that the Earth is round yeah it says you
know what if if I play along if I do
this Flat Earth thing I'll have some
buddies we'll have a good time that girl
over there she's pretty cute
that's that's how Cults recruit
political groups occur political
ideology also is a way of recruiting
people's all the same it's all
interrelated
things are not
qualitatively different they're just
kind of quantitatively different like
here
Legends become hero worship
becomes mythology
becomes religion
becomes philosophy
becomes politics
it's there's there's an evolutionary
line in that it's so it's it's all about
the same thing it's just the the
quantity of it is different it goes from
talking [__] to trying to write [__]
down and trying to organize things and
then fashion it into something you can
actually apply and then there's
something you can vote for or fight for
you know
they're they're doing the same thing
well yeah and I'm and I was gonna say I
it was kind of instructive to me too
it's like and I kind of knew this like I
said from dealing with creationists and
stuff because it's very very similar but
the thing about it is that a lot of them
I'm not saying a lot of them don't
genuinely believe it they probably do
but I think a large part of it is like
Tom said like psychological a lot of it
is social because it's not
it's not that a lot of them I'm not
going to say like that a lot of them
were losers or anything like that
because I don't know I don't know them
but it did seem like
prior to them finding Flat Earth they
maybe had some other weird kind of like
Fringe beliefs because a lot of them the
thing about it is if you're a flat Earth
person then that's not the only
conspiracy you believe in you generally
can believe in like pretty much all the
other ones too because it's all part of
that same mindset and
um Patricia steer that woman on there
she even said that she considers Flat
Earth like the The Hub of the spider web
or some of all the other conspiracies so
a lot of them do like kind of believe
and they found that like I said
psychological studies like hundreds and
hundreds of Studies have been done and
it's like people that believe in one
conspiracy you can't you know they're
like Lay's potato chips you can't just
have just one
um if you believe in one then you
believe in other ones too because it's a
psychological type it's a you know it's
it's a mindset
so so these people have that mindset and
maybe they had some weird beliefs
whether it was Flat Earth or whether it
was some other stuff like I said
reptilians or whatever the [__] whether
it was that and maybe they didn't they
so maybe these weird beliefs like kind
of isolated them like from friends and
family maybe people were like yeah
that's pretty weird I don't really want
to hang out with that person or whatever
so I feel like they were maybe kind of
lonely and then when they got into Flat
Earth and found this like large
relatively thriving community and they
all seemed like really nice people and
it's like this was they all wanted to
talk about the same kind of stuff and
they have like all these meetups and
stuff so they wanted to do that and like
I said it became part of their identity
and it was just very instructive to me
that a lot of people at the convention
or not really talking about
you know some of them were like talking
about oh we got to do scientific proofs
of Flat Earth but most of them were
talking about the sense of community
that they had found like one guy on
there that this kind of made me sad but
like this one guy that was on there and
he was like wanted to hug Mark Sargent
and everything like that because he was
kind of the guy I don't know if he
organized it but he's like one of the
main guys in the movement and he
basically this other guy said I was
tired of being called an idiot
and it's like so I guess he found like a
circle of like-minded people that
wouldn't make fun of him for having
these weird ass beliefs and so and the
thing about it too and much like a cult
once you get into it like that and you
have all of this camaraderie and
everybody that has the same world view
as you then it's really difficult to get
out because if you get out then all your
friends are also Gone Van friel's saying
well don't you always don't you always
arrive when you're supposed to he's
talking about the time when I was
talking about the map yeah you always
arrive when you're supposed to if it's a
sphere
okay but if you were to flatten it out
you would increase the distance between
the two
points where you left and where you
wanted to arrive so it would take longer
if it doesn't happen because it's a
sphere well the weird thing too and this
is another thing that kind of blows my
mind
is that I mean it doesn't really because
I kind of know why they do it but in the
documentary Mark Sargent one of the uh
one of the arguments that he made for
like Flat Earth was like a [__]
straight face he says this like outright
he says you can go because you know how
you can go online and like look at all
the plane flights that are happening
like at any time like uh you know on any
given day or whatever
and he's like so I went in there and I
noticed that there he said there weren't
any in the southern hemisphere going to
or coming from the southern hemisphere
right isn't that what he said yeah well
because if you had a flat Earth and like
the southern hemisphere is way around
the outside of the disc right so it's
like super far yeah so he said that
there were none and then they just
showed they showed this other woman on
there who was an astrophysicist or
something and she goes on the same
website and she's like what there's
[__] flights yeah she's like this is
very easy to debunk it's like so why
would you say that out loud oh I sat
there for two or three days looking for
flights and there weren't any and I'm
just she's like obviously there are
flights right she brought that up she
brought that up to show you either one
or two things either he's admitting what
he's seeing he's omitting it on purpose
yeah okay which means he's full of [__]
yeah either way he knows that he's full
of [__] he knows this around he just
doesn't want to say that I think he
knows because it's like a religion
imagine okay let's let's say imagine you
prove that Jesus never lived that he was
a Roman god
okay uh that he never lived at all to
say you were able to prove that
Christians would never believe that they
would say no there was a Jesus no matter
what you said
that's what he's doing they're saying he
he it's proven to him over and over
again at the Earth is a sphere but he's
going no no no it's flat that's all he's
doing
yeah and they're not because he has to
be in the call right he can't let all
his buddies down there's peer pressure
I mean then he's going to lose all the
benefits of being in the co right and I
mean honestly Mark Sergeant I feel like
probably has more to lose than most
because I as far as I'm aware
um he now makes a full-time living at
that
there's just a certain psychology of
there's a certain kind of person that
falls into this they seek it out
it's the kind of people they are yeah he
just didn't want to do it with a
conventional religion so he goes to
something very unconventional he finds
that and then he starts developing that
same kind of guy that would join
Scientology
basically yeah it's like I said it's
it's a mindset it's not
um
so so that's why you see because like I
said you know it if you believe in Flat
Earth it's not just flat Earth they
believe in lots of a bunch of other
shares right yeah it's kind of cool when
you think about it it's a large extended
Universe of [__] alternate thinking
it's not right but it's very eventive
the [__] crazy [__] they've come up
with to explain why it's flat
when the easiest explanation is that
it's a sphere
that's the easiest everything makes
sense when it's a sphere yeah
and the fact that they don't believe in
gravity which well see that's another
thing because if the if the Earth was
indeed the way that they described yeah
there would essentially be no gravity
yeah gravity wouldn't work because
there's been nothing to pull the earth
into a sphere right
and in a lot of things just wouldn't
work they said well it just falls to the
ground because it's heavy but what makes
it heavy gravity makes it heavy yeah
well that's what I mean it's like so I'm
one like the glow Busters guys they're
arguing essentially that gravity isn't
real I don't think they ever came out
and said that but that's what they were
implying but then they were using terms
like buoyancy and density I'm like
that's gravity do you understand that
those are the same thing that's the same
Force
gravity but you need balloons to hold
satellites up in space
because they can't say there's an orbit
right if there's an orbit that means
it's a sphere that's what I mean it's
just it's like why are you making
something so hard complicated you're
just making everything complicated the
model doesn't work and it doesn't make
sense because it's like every single so
like everything single thing that you
could come up with that that a spherical
earth like very easily explains yeah
you're like okay well what about this
like I said just night and day something
as easy as something as observable as
that that everybody can see you ask them
to explain that and they have to come up
with these [__] convoluted
explanation for this like why are you
doing this to yourself and also what
they're saying is they're saying tens of
millions of people over over a period of
maybe a hot couple hundred years 400
years maybe 300 years
have conspired
to fake outer space
the entirety of outer space the entirety
of outer space the idea that planets and
moons are spheres oh they they made that
up that's a total lie uh the idea that
the sun is in the center of the solar
system you know the solar system is part
of a galaxy that that no
they they can't it's just no everything
starts breaking down when you're a flat
earther nothing works no nothing works
now like I said you can very clearly see
okay what is okay so what are the other
primitive people knew yeah
because it's the only thing that makes
sense yeah it's not it's maybe not
intuitive yeah but once you know that
you're like oh of course yeah of course
that's the only thing that makes sense
there's nothing else does yeah even
educated people in the Middle Ages the
Dark Ages knew that it was [__] that
the Earth was a sphere
yeah yeah they knew everybody because
they were reading Greek books yeah
Greeks knew it Greeks and the Romans all
knew that yeah
uh Greeks and the Romans well the Romans
definitely had had a very modern
modernistic approach if you read their
writings it's like this sounds like
there's written yesterday
totally modern people yeah so they don't
have all the fancy [__] we have no they
just figured it out through guess what
personal observation yeah and they also
knew that Roman religions were just were
kind of made up
they believed in nature
the educated people Roman religions were
made up it was just to bind the society
together and give uneducated people
Something to Believe In and to give
people hope and that they were promoted
values and it was a way of teaching
people how to behave and that they were
good
Romans actually believed educated Romans
knew that religions were not true most
of us
but they believed most of them were good
that people needed well in the sense
that they get people out of trouble well
they well they were good because people
need things to believe in well I would
no I wasn't going to say that I was
going to say that humans um
they take in information a lot easier
when it's put in story form yeah right
so
um so if you put something in a
narrative form then people are gonna
because if you start coming at them with
like abstract facts and [__] like that
which you know that's kind of ties back
to what we're talking about with the
flat earthers the second you start
talking about math and [__] like that
they they pretend they understand it but
they don't because the thing about it is
that some of the [__] and especially
when I was watching like the globusters
and stuff like that they were very smug
and very condescending thinking they
understood science better than actual
scientists even though neither of them
is a scientist obviously and haven't
really studied any of this stuff but
it's like the way that they talked you
could very clearly understand that they
didn't have all they were doing was like
parroting back things that they had
heard in other YouTube videos yeah they
were talking points they didn't have any
fundamental understanding of what they
were saying yeah they just knew set
talking points of the cult right they
didn't know you know what I mean they
didn't it wasn't like you know if you
study science and you go to college and
you do the experiments yourself and like
see how it works and [__] like that
because they do make you replicate like
old experiences so you can see for
yourself like how it works right so they
make you do that but they never did that
so they won they assumed nobody else
ever did that either
um but two they don't really seem they
have no like fundamental understanding
they're just repeating stuff back that
they heard which is and here's the thing
parroting and repeating things back that
you heard
uh very common among the [__] human
species that's happening everywhere all
the time all people everywhere around
the Earth
uh if you have friends in other cultures
they they'll tell you that they have
basically stereotypes that they repeat
over and over again about themselves and
foreigners everybody does that and it's
just because of the way cultures work
well human brains are brains work
certain ways and yeah there's an in
always an in-group and an out group
there's all kinds of weird just because
you believe something is true does not
mean it's true
chances are you got that belief
from someone else
all right and had been repeated over and
over again and it's not your belief it's
a belief that you picked up don't really
believe anything until you know for sure
you can prove it uh you're gonna find it
oh yeah this actually is something that
I was told to believe in but that's
actually not true like okay here's an
example give you a very easy example
I was taught that Marco Polo was a
historical figure that actually existed
no Marco Polo never existed and he never
went to China
but that's that's shocking to a lot of
people although modern people probably
never even heard of Marco Polo
there was no Marco Polo the oldest
[__] additions of the Marco Polo is
obviously a [__] science fiction book
about a dude that never existed who
supposedly went to China and met dog
heads and people that had [__] faces
in the center of their chest and became
a Chinese warlord and came back and
brought noodles it's a totally fictional
story but as time went on that book
became more detailed and more
historicized where it sounded more real
the Chinese have no record of any Marco
Polo ever coming to see them and every
description about Marco Polo in that
book every description of China does not
match up with historical reality none of
it
it was a book of fiction it was Star
Wars
well yeah and that happens a lot
especially like I said the farther uh
away we are for something like
historically yeah how easy it is to like
mix up fiction and facts yeah because
you don't know like if they just wrote
that as a mythology or somebody wrote
that as a novel or a story or something
like that and then somebody picked it up
and that book was printed over and over
and over and over again for like 200
years and each time it got sounded more
and more historical it was fiction
there's wild yeah you know there's a lot
of stuff in Western culture that's like
that well I unless you are confronted
about something I think a lot of people
don't
I mean the the kind of core beliefs that
they have or maybe something like that a
lot of people don't really question them
it's I mean if they don't have cause too
like you know the fact that Marco Polo
didn't exist that's not really something
that people are going to be thinking
about on a daily basis yeah it's like
yeah maybe you learned about it in
school or something like that but then
you kind of forgot about it right but
then if somebody told but you know it
doesn't have anything to do with your
day-to-day life so right exactly but
there's a lot of things that people take
for granted here in the United States
and the West about history okay that
they believe happened but it didn't
happen it was just a narrative
history is a narrative
uh it's you've chosen selectively to
tell a story based upon things that have
happened to paint a story uh when that's
not how reality actually works a lot
more happens and a lot more a lot of
different places and this is because you
think that occurrences was more
important than the other occurrences
you're choosing that one to make more of
a narrative yeah you can nail down
certain dates when things happen but
other things happened at other dates
that may have been more important and
more influential to the [__] course
of history
but those dates are not traditionally
shown to you those occurrences are not
traditionally shown as being important
so history I I [__] saw a whole
program on how history is very deceptive
uh regimes change history by
tweaking things and turning things into
a story
well history is harder yeah it's hard
because it's not it's harder to get a
handle on yeah and it's usually like I
said it's easier the the farther away it
is right here because you have some
perspective on it you can see the
outcome yeah most so you can focus on
what it was that led up to them most of
American history about the revolution is
is mythology in a way you know the way
the revolution had happened uh
it looked real heroic in American and
yeah all this good [__] with George
Washington we lost almost every battle
okay uh the [__] American
revolutionaries uh were not peaceful
they were [__] violent all right they
broke into people's houses raped
people's wives and [__] burn people's
houses down when they didn't agree with
the revolution it was it was kind of
like the French Revolution all right but
that's been omitted
uh a lot of the French a lot of the
American Revolution was involved with
intimidating judges and [__] there's
a lot of stuff that happened but that's
not really talked about
um yeah the American Revolution happened
it's just that it didn't succeed for the
reasons most people think it was and it
wasn't a lot of people involved in it
actually I think it was only like three
percent of the people actually took a
[__] active role and most people
didn't give a [__]
thank you very much Bryce yeah 20 New
Zealand Dollars ancient Polynesians knew
the Earth was round it's even in the
mythology the Earth is compared to a
coconut yeah that's how they sailed the
oceans of course yeah I mean if you were
uh at an even back then if you were in
any way like dependent on ship
navigation you had to know it was around
uh you had to know that it was round
um I'm sorry but never [__] figure it
out you'd never arrived and [__] even I
was again I was watching something Bill
Nye the Science Guy he's like please
read some books about navigation it's
like they were very
they knew how the [__] worked okay it's
like you would have to now um Sebastian
brings up a point uh scientists don't
lie do they well yeah everybody lies
sometimes but see that's the thing and
we've kind of talked about this a little
bit when we were running the documentary
last day because one of the
psychologists that was on there that was
talking about maybe like where some of
these people were coming from and he's
like well once you once you're coming
from a mindset that everyone is lying to
you the government is lying to you the
scientists are lying to you like you
don't trust anyone then it's like then
you can go into I think he said you can
go into all kind of corners
and the thing about that is that I I
think when you because I'm a very
pro-science person
but it's not
um like a zero-sum game it's not one or
the other it's just like I kind of feel
like there's there's this sort of
dichotomy between people that are like
oh well we can't trust anyone like
government scientists or anybody like
that even though they'll trust like a
random YouTuber but whatever yeah he's
on the team right that's well that's
that's called confirmation exactly um
you know that they're saying something
you want to already believe so it's like
oh well I believe that guy but I won't
believe any of these people that are
saying something like contrary to what I
wanted it's human nature so yeah so
that's what it is but like I said that's
why there's a thing called confirmation
bias because speaking of the dream
that's yeah full strength full size or
um yeah might as well I mean you know
it's fine as well full full of right
might as well okay like I said I got to
work tomorrow but [__] it whatever
although I'll probably feel different
when I get up at five tomorrow and I'm
like why why did I do that it's okay
um but yeah that one wasn't that strong
anyway
but the thing about it is that
it's it's not one or the other it's like
yeah and I'm not saying that the
government doesn't lie obviously they do
sometimes scientists lie or they're paid
off or but obviously but the fact that
that happens sometimes it doesn't follow
that that happens all the time and the
thing about it is that
science is not really I kind of feel too
that people that have a more dogmatic
point of view like flat earthers like
creationists like people like that that
are into like certain conspiracies that
are more dogmatic
um than reasoned even though I'm sure
they wouldn't categorize it that way
um they are going to say like any
evidence that you give them like that is
contrary to what they already believe
they're just gonna dismiss it they're
gonna say it's fake as much as they want
as much as they ask you show me evidence
of this show me evidence that flat
earthers do it creationists do it it's
like well show me evidence show me how
this could have evolved like
creationists used to go it's like oh
well show me how the eye evolves so like
many scientists were like Well here
here's like several examples in nature
and this is where this was where it was
convergent evolution and here's their
that the other oh well that's not they
will always like find some excuse as to
why that wasn't relevant or why that
wasn't so you can tell that they don't
want to believe they don't really want
evidence they just are playing at
science but the thing about science and
P people that have a dogmatic worldview
I kind of feel like they think science
works the same way as Dogma does because
you can see it in a lot of the things
they're just like oh people are
brainwashed to believe this or you know
um you know science they even call it
scientism like they're trying to put it
on the same level but it's like science
is not a Dogma it's just a method it's a
method of getting to
um you know the truth it's a method of
you know building up like testing things
and stuff like that until you get to the
truth it's not it's not a foregone
conclusion it's not anything like that
I'm not saying that some scientists
aren't [__] up and like they do stuff
wrong and like you know I'm not saying
that and that some scientists can be
dogmatic too but I'm just saying that
the process in itself is not dogmatic
it's actually the opposite of that so I
kind of feel like another problem too is
that because they see the world
dogmatically then they think that
everyone else like thinks like that too
and they don't like I don't think like
that
um and a lot of other people don't
either
and like I said you know that they think
like that because the experiments that
they do
um to prove that the Earth is flat
they've already settled on the
conclusion they've already settled on
the conclusion that the Earth is flat
they already believe that and they're
just looking for things that will
confirm that that is not an experiment
that's not how you do it
if you're doing an experiment the way
you're supposed to do it you're not
really supposed to you you can predict
like what the outcome is going to be but
if it comes out different then you're
like huh okay well that didn't come out
the way I expect let's check and see you
know maybe I'm wrong
um they don't really seem to have the
mindset of if the experiment because it
kind of blew my mind a little bit where
the dude at the end with the laser thing
like through the holes and it didn't
work which obviously I knew it wasn't
gonna happen like obviously that's not
going to work and it didn't and then all
he did was just like look at the thing
like oh interesting
did he like say oh maybe I'm wrong maybe
the Earth is curved no of course not
same thing with the guy that with the
[__] gyroscope oh maybe I'm wrong
maybe they're maybe the Earth is moving
maybe there is a five percent drift
which just like everybody said that they
figured out like a long time ago maybe
maybe I'm wrong they never do that
though they always dig in further and
come up with some wildly convoluted
explanations yes for why the [__] came
out the way they did it yeah and I'm
watching this and I'm going religion I'm
seeing it it is definitely yeah
they've decided that this is true
even if they know it's false this is
true but this is the passage this is the
ticket you have to have to be in the
club so they have to defend it at all
you know they're going to defend it to
the death even though they know it's not
true
but they have to be in this club
well and I think there's something of uh
you know maybe like a little bit of the
sunk cost fallacy where you're just kind
of like I'm so invested in this now that
it's like I can't get out one all looks
stupid
um too I'll like lose my whole
livelihood or I'll lose all my friends
or I'll lose my social group or
something like that because they're too
invested in it I think it mostly has to
do with social group because look at it
this way a person would say well if I
can score a good
hit against the enemy I'll get street
cred and I might be able to be able to
pick up that girl over there and I'll
impress her I've been trying to go out
with her it's it's that kind of [__]
it's that simple
yeah you know or I'll be able to impress
my friends it does seem like even though
they know it wasn't a real Victory
largely they they seem to get into it
for emotional reasons they don't really
seem to get as much as they might argue
otherwise no it's emotional um they yeah
this is something that even if they do
believe that the Earth is flat which
some of them seem to because I kind of
thought nobody can really believe that
come on but some of them actually do
seem genuinely sincere I don't know if
deep down they really believe it but up
front they definitely do seem sincere in
their belief and I just kind of feel
like
I don't know maybe this is just
something that makes them feel better
like I said because it makes them feel
special it makes them feel unique and
again I think it's coming from a a
religious standpoint because it's like
it's it's putting humans
putting the Earth back into the center
of things whereas you know we I feel
like over the course of and and you see
this kind of thing happening every time
like a big scientific you know
Revolution comes along like I said they
happen with Evolution it happened with
other things where you know where humans
get knocked down a pig or Earth gets
knocked down a pig oh you know we're not
we're you know we uh you know evolve
from like a common ancestor with apes or
you know uh the Earth isn't the center
of the universe and stuff like that like
some people get very very upset by that
and they find it more comforting
um to be in the center of things like to
be important and to be special and like
I said that's not inherently bad um
everybody wants to be special but
everything is special all animals are
special I mean when you think about it I
mean me coming from like more of like a
scientific framework like a scientific
mindset to me that's how I see things
I'm just like you know what I mean it's
like like it I kind of think I know this
is like kind of weird to say but it's
like every time you're just kind of like
you know if we like ran over a frog or
something like that like on the road and
I get uh what a waste and I get really
upset about it and Tom's like yeah but
they got lots of those I'm like yeah but
there was only one of him yeah yeah yeah
you know what I mean yeah that was it
that's never gonna happen again yeah but
you have to understand a lot of them are
born I know that a lot of them are done
but see that's what I think I do know
that yeah and most of the food for other
things I know that's what happens to
them I know that and uh but the fact
that I know being eaten by something it
got squashed by something yeah the only
ones that really kind of bother me but I
still you still gotta go hey
[__] happens it wasn't our fault it just
happens is when you do something like
remember to hit the raccoon yeah oh that
was [__] up yeah yeah because it was
it wasn't alone it was with his buddies
and I hit the raccoon and I guess killed
the raccoon I I just kept driving I was
like I don't want to know and the other
little buddies I saw in the freaking
rear view mirror turned back to go get
him I was like I can't handle it yeah
that upset me a lot but I try to stop
they were like Carl yeah I tried to stop
but there was no way they jumped right
out in front of the car in the middle of
the night they did there was no time to
stop I mean they jumped out in front of
the foot and I only had maybe about 30
feet to stop and that car was not gonna
stop at 30 feet I hit the brakes and I
heard it hit
somewhere around the door and the wheel
didn't go over him but I heard his head
hit the undercarriage
and they don't usually survive that
even though I was probably only going
about 40. but I mean I still think about
that yeah to be honest and I was like oh
I didn't mean and because like I said
you know maybe a lot of people think oh
it was just a raccoon or it's just a
frog or whatever but I'm just like that
was the only one of those that was the
only one of him well the raccoons are
cute and they're
at least as intelligent as a cat and
they have good personalities a lot of
them if you watch them they'll go into
people's people that feed them they'll
eventually come into the house and let
you pet them and [__] and they're Wild
they'll come hang out with you because
you feed them and then they leave
so you know they're they're nice little
creatures like there's a girl that I
watch her name Hannah Baron she's uh
down in Alabama cute little Southern
Girl Who noodles catfish and
catch his stuff
she did a video where she was trapping
and I never agreed with Travis trapping
was kind of against
hunting culture in Laurel Mississippi
where I was growing up my dad and his
buddies trapping was something you'd
only did
when times were really hard and you had
to get some meat by any means necessary
but she was trapping
raccoons
so she could get a uh she wanted to make
a raccoon blanket
I was like and she was she was using it
she was using an iron bar that had a
[__] little cone-shaped thing where
you could put peanut butter in there and
it'll reach him with their hand and grab
the peanut butter but they can't pull
her hand how can you do that so then she
just walk up to she never they didn't
show her do it but what then what you do
is you walk up to the thing and [__]
hit it on the head with a [__]
steel bar I couldn't do that yeah this
cute little animals go no no please
don't do it I never trapped and I think
it's cruel it is it's horrible and it's
too much stress on the animal
look I eat meat but it's like as long as
like the animal is killed like as though
they don't know what hit them yeah I
mean it's a lot different and then
another thing is is that really I only
kill animals for food
she wasn't killing those things for food
I don't I I it's like you can just buy a
blanket yeah at Walmart okay she wanted
a wrecking a blanket I'm going like
see I'm questioning the motives for that
like why would you need that why would
you like just see it's like a waste
she'd build her own house
did she build her house out of raccoon
bones no she knew that it would and uh
she built it out we built her own house
and she had this little bitty cabin type
house and it was it was pretty little
house but she wanted everything to be
real rustic and like Furs and and wood
and so she wanted this raccoon I mean
there's in this day and age there's
really no reason
to do that there's just don't kill
animals unless you're gonna eat them
yeah I mean another trap other than like
stunting which right just [__] off with
that and uh oh yeah your advice is you
big you big tough Hunter you you killed
a little cute little raccoon good for
you that was I don't think that's what
what her thinking was
she was just kind of mechanical about it
um the uh which I thought was kind of
cold I was like man those are cute
animals uh that's like killing cats you
know and like I don't I've had big I
said hey I got these coyotes on my
[__] property and I'm [__] what
what's a good thing to use because they
know that I I bow hunt too you know but
I haven't been bow hunting a long time
my bows downstairs
I don't kill coyotes coyotes are dogs
okay I couldn't I don't kill dogs all
right uh I don't wouldn't kill wolves
either that's just a dog yeah it's
different than a dog but it's a dog all
right those uh I kill game animals I
wouldn't shoot a bear a bear is not a
game animal
all right it's
they're kind of
leave Bears alone okay they're not an
apex predator and a [__] black bear
is more just like a an opportunist uh
they're not dangerous uh run into them
all the time yeah people have been
killed by it but a lot of times it's a
misunderstanding
and uh you shooting a random [__]
black bear in the woods is not killing a
dangerous animal
it's just not most of those things are
friendly walking around just sitting
around and being goofy as [__] when you
see him you know and if you were to walk
up on one it would run away
they're not they're not mean most of
them just like people
see so
what I'm saying is that coming at things
from a scientific standpoint actually I
think makes you more
um aware of how unique every single yeah
creature is yeah because that's a DNA
combination that is completely
singular yeah and like I was saying
black bears are very Advanced creatures
they're not all the same they're they're
individuals just because one person got
killed by an angry black bear
who may have been [__] getting
revenge over [__] having
a family member shot okay doesn't mean
you shoot in some [__] random girl
bear [__] rolling around on her back
you know what I mean that's not right
it's not yeah no well it's kind of weird
that was a person you just I'ma shoot
this girl because some random person
because some dude killed him dude what's
the difference they're all the same
right no they're not well people do you
know people do kind of if something is
not like you yeah
um then you tend to make them feel like
they're all the same you know what I
mean you see well that's the whole basis
of racism but people do it with animals
like you think all animals of one
species are the same yeah like if you
have a cat or a dog you know all cats
are not the same yeah they have
personalities dogs have personalities
yeah they're all different so you can't
hold the whole species responsible
responsible for the misbehavior or or
some accident that happened with one of
now we were talking about sharks that's
a different [__] situation they're
very primitive sharks are all about the
same
even Dolphins know that but Dolphins
aren't the same no yeah they're a lot
more advanced
dolphin shark fight yeah Dolphins don't
like sharks oh there's no think about it
I'm gonna say about sharks because I was
gonna bring up sharks actually after
Jaws came out do you know that like
everybody started killing sharks because
they thought they were and Steven
Spielberg felt really bad about that
yeah because because sharks are jaws
well yeah well it's like it's very rare
and it's like and I'm still not going to
the ocean because I don't want to get
killed by getting bitten in half by a
shark that's one of my nightmares but um
but generally I mean sharks generally do
not attack humans like it's very very
very very very very very very unlikely
that you will be attacked by a shark but
because of Jaws
um Everybody decided sharks are the
enemies so they just started like
[__] sharks have a niche they have a
niche yeah you're like [__] it you're
[__] up the ecosystem yeah
Dolphins don't like if Dolphins hate
them but you know and it's only certain
sharks that [__] Dolphins hate they
don't hate all sharks either
it's just depends on what kind of shirt
what kind of shirts some sharks are
chill yeah but yeah so um where we got
like way off from like flattered but the
thing about it is that what I was saying
when you were in the other room was that
I think the problem arises
because
flat earthers like creationists are
coming at things from a dogmatic
world view whereas scientists are coming
at things from a scientific worldview
and those two things are diametrically
opposed yeah Bryce Trap and Fish don't
count
fish are like robots
yeah yeah I'm talking about land animals
mammals and [__] don't you that should
be should be trapping them it's cruel
yeah it I mean it is yeah
but um but yeah so and the thing about
it and much like the creationists did
with the whole intelligent design thing
um when they started getting called out
for [__] like oh well your point of view
is just religious and that's if that's
all you have to back it up then you
don't have anything then they started
like trying to encroach on Sciences
territory but without the fundamental
understanding of what the scientific
framework was like how what how the
scientific method worked or anything
like that and I think that's the same
thing you're seeing with the flat
earthers and I could kind of see it like
I said in the globuster guys like just
the way that they talked and the things
that they said I think there's this
weird kind of like in within that
community and like I said I'm not saying
they're stupid because a lot of them
aren't but I think a lot of people that
don't
understand
um you know if they don't understand
like higher physics or they're not good
at math or something like that maybe
deep down they feel insecure about that
and so they almost kind of go in the
opposite direction and pretend they know
more about it than people that actually
know about it it's like this weird like
distrust of like expertise
um and more like we're just gonna go
with like our gut feelings and stuff
which is fine in some situations but in
these bigger picture kind of situations
I think that is like not the best way to
go about things and I but I think these
dudes are like using that they're like
well I don't understand that formula
therefore it's wrong that seemed like
the whole extent of their they didn't
say that outright but the way that they
were talking around it that's what it
sounded like to me because they didn't
understand it they didn't understand the
math behind it they didn't understand
the physics they didn't understand any
of it so it must not be right
because what's right is what I can see
what I can touch
um you know so if you're trying to like
go all highfalutin I mean they were even
making fun of Professor Dave for oh
those big words and they weren't even
big words like it was like Quantum
something it was like Quantum
calculations I think was the term that
he used and I'm like those are not big
words
um I'm not really sure why you think
they are it's like just because you
don't know what they mean that doesn't
mean that other people don't know what
they mean
I think that's another thing too and
like I said that's kind of getting back
to the Dunn and Kruger thing which
Professor Dave brought up a lot in that
video is that dun and Kruger is
basically like if you don't know [__]
you don't know enough to know all of the
[__] that you don't know yeah whereas
people that actually know [__] are
actually kind of insecure because
they're like holy [__] there's all this
other [__] that I don't know that they
know about but they don't you know what
I mean they there's they're much more
cognizant of all the [__] that they
don't know whereas people that don't
know anything think they already know
they're that they know everything there
is to know because they don't know [__]
Oscar's in there what's up Oscar hey
what's up he's asking if we saw somebody
getting eaten by a shark down in Egypt
or something so now we didn't see it see
I don't think I could watch that that
would just give me really bad nightmares
I mean like to me like I don't this is
why I don't go in the ocean anymore I
used to when I was a kid because I used
to live right on the ocean but
I don't do that [__] oh [__] isn't a
problem here in Florida problem here is
[__] these creeks and [__]
alligators I don't want to get eaten by
an alligator I saw a video of people
free I wanted to get it eaten by
anything I saw a video of people
freaking out they're taking their phone
and they're [__] poking it over the
[__] edge of the little of a little
uh
bridge going over a little bitty Creek
and there's an alligator Swimming by
with a dead woman in its mouth she's
floating on us remember that one she's
in her [__] dress I would not have
watched that and and he's I would have
just read the description and been like
nope yeah I don't want that image in my
head no yes he had he had her by the
ankle she was dead floating on top of
the water and he's just swimming with
her and taking her taking her down to
somewhere to let her rot up so he could
eat them because [__] they can't
really eat fresh meat they can't chew
so they have to let you rot I still I
still have an image in my head of that
that alligator trainer or like the guy
that worked at that got his hand bitten
off like that famous photo that went
viral of like the alligator with the
hand in his mouth yeah like the severed
hand which a lot of people thought was
fake but it wasn't they actually like
went back and found the dude that it
happened to I mean they've had
families show up here to Disneyland and
an alligator run up out of the damn
[__] yeah I got eaten right there in
the [__] park on the right there in
the parking lot ready it wasn't it was
out outside of one of the resorts well
yeah but that was near the parking lot
you didn't see that that alligator ran
up out of the [__] water and grabbed
that little boy and [__] drug his ass
underneath the water never found him
again are they get the body
I don't know did they recover it I can't
remember now
you got to watch it man yeah it was full
they'll get little kids and they'll get
dogs and it doesn't matter like how
built up there if that was the [__]
Disney Resort yeah Disney Resort there's
alligators every is there's a body
there's all kinds of [__] if there's a
body of water just assume that there's
alligators yeah because there probably
are probably well you can check you go
out there at night with a flashlight you
go
surface if you see eyes gleaming back at
you it's an alligator I just assume that
everybody of water of any significant
size has alligators in it I had to check
every night Pookie was running down with
a [__] Creek Lake little bitty she
doesn't go outside anymore yeah and make
sure there's no alligators in there so
she could go
yeah cause she like to go look at the
lake that Lake was probably too small
but yeah well it doesn't matter that's
what I mean it's just like but you can
never be sure it was probably at least
two or three feet deep in the center but
an alligator that that's fine for an
alligator and I think they're worth less
fish in it an alligator will go in there
to see if there's anything there yeah
and if there's nothing there they'll
leave because they go from like Ponte
they go from Pawn to Pond that will
cross the road looking for water yeah
Jeffy Hart said yeah they did find the
child's body they did fine they held the
service at Epcot okay yeah that's like
that's fine can you imagine like coming
like you save all this money it's like
we're gonna go to Disney and she'll like
imagine that happening that's like the
[__] worst thing yeah alligator eat
your kid and Disney was right I
apologizing
I mean it wasn't Disney's fault there's
like alligators everywhere it's Florida
but you know what I mean it's just kind
of like still what a [__] thing to
happen man yeah I can't imagine
some of them things are [__] huge
alligators are scary like I said I was
driving [__] you I was driving from
Daytona to DeLand one time on 92 which
is a road I now take to work every
single day
and I was just driving and randomly an
alligator just ran across the highway
yeah ran across the highway
and there's a photograph the car almost
hit it there's a photograph of it it was
big too is a photograph of one somebody
got it on the camera got it on their
phone going across the dab
course and that [__] must be 20 foot
from [__] yeah he's [__] huge he
looks like a dragon
yeah he's a big [__] walking it wasn't
even dragging his belly across the
ground he was standing up walking
must have been a foot of clearance
Underneath Him actually nearly the road
to my elementary school when I was
younger
um uh an alligator got hit on the road
there yeah and like its body was like on
the side of the road for a long time
like when I was going to school
I was like nope that's a dead alligator
again so like a guy hit by a car but
yeah I saw one running across the
[__] highway
one time so I promise to wrestle an
alligator on a show a couple years back
but you did right yeah I'm gonna have to
go get an alligator
I can't take a big alligator about six
foot I nah five foot I could probably
take six
you got to get on top and hold its mouth
shut and then you gotta start taping his
mouth closed and [__] pull him out
and get him out of the way you always
need to tape their mouths close yeah
because they have they have a lot of
bite force down but not not so much uh
yeah so if you can like do that I mean
I'm not advising this but I'm just
saying if you can get your hands around
their snout which some of them it's kind
of too big to do that but if you can do
that like they usually can't I saw a
news report recently that they found a
headless
alligator on the side of the road
no explanation
it was in a in a
suburban area
maybe something like around Stanford
interesting yeah I found a headless
alligator somebody found it in their
pool and was like not having it cut his
head off they probably used its head for
something because that's another thing
some people wake up in the morning and
go out with their morning coffee out on
the patio and they're like oh there's an
alligator in my pool gotta call animal
control that's one of the most I think
the most common thing Animal Control
deals with is like raccoons in people's
roofs and like addicts and stuff but I
think alligator in the pool is probably
like the second most common or maybe
snakes and Bears all the time used to
see Bears all the time at her old house
I'm working on a bike and I thought
someone was watching me and looked up
[__] there's a bear looking at me
standing right there
[__] entrance way the [__] garage
and I said what's up Baron and it ran
yeah if you interact with them just be
friendly with them they'll run
uh let me see wait a minute I saw some
stuff oh Oscar said that Disney
alligator attack on the two-year-old was
absolutely terrible yeah it was it was
awful like I said I can't imagine this
is Diego but man this is Florida but
it's like you don't expect yeah in the
middle of civilization right but yeah
like I said it doesn't really matter how
built up the area is I just assume and
if you come to Florida you should
probably assume that any body of water
has an alligator in it it might not but
I would just assume just be on the safe
side you could be in so keep your kids
away from it keep your pets away from it
seriously and I'm like not even joking
you could be on the edge of the city
in a [__] nice housing complex looks
like [__] damn porn scene gonna
happen at any moment and a bear or an
alligator [__] stand right there
walking across your parking or maybe a
panther if you're lucky yeah yeah I have
seen a couple of those they're friendly
though they're friendly well Panthers
aren't but you know uh they'll just run
probably they mostly just run Mrs Evans
already party said my second day in your
great state was the morning after the
pulse shootings oh yeah I remember that
we were downtown then we're downtown we
were like a blocker and I had a bad
feeling something's gonna happen I said
we got to get out of here uh and the
week of the Disney Gator yeah that's
right that was all the same time yeah we
might have had bad luck yeah yeah sorry
um
although you know what's funny is that
you know yeah that was a dude shot that
place up and he got killed and
everything a bunch of people died
it didn't make any difference here
[__] next weekend it was still
[__] rolling
civilization's tough you don't let
people like that defeat you like oh well
that's it we can't go out now well
that's the thing it's like even if it
did drop off for a couple weeks after a
while you're just kind of like man you
can't let one [__] like just
control your life the club we hung out
with [__] uh [__] one of the
bouncers there kicked a dude out and
then [__] the dude went back to his
car [__] got a 22 came back started
shooting at the [__] bar he was
[__] he was trying to get in and he
was yeah he shot at the door he didn't
hurt anybody he didn't hurt anybody and
he's doing this right next to police
station the cops came out and [__]
got his ass yeah the police station was
literally right there around the corner
like [__] from where the club used to
20 meters from there and yeah it was
like Club pizza place police station it
was like right there and uh dude didn't
know where he was I guess or didn't care
um and then there was another one where
uh this happened downtown
dude was just drunk as [__]
at the bar
and reaches in his pocket and pulls out
a [__] pistol and puts it on the
[__] desk or on the on the bar and
the whole bar clears out and he's just
drunk as [__]
and um
the cut they call the cops
he starts walking out of the [__]
club
out of the bar
and the cop tries to shoot him misses
him and shoots the [__] bartender
girl
remember that remember that happened and
then I think that guy shot himself
or the cop shot him I don't know I don't
remember but he was just so blasted that
dude was so drunk he didn't know where
he was
it was just one it's one of the weird
things that happens
[__] uh these dudes don't make any
[__] sense
dudes in general don't make any [__]
sense
at least not to me like no [__] sense
he got so drunk he just pulled a pistol
out put it online it was and he was like
falling down drunk
yeah Jeffy art said the club where I
work at security is right across the
street from the Wilton vanders Police
Department yeah yeah the club we go to
now I mean where it used to be was right
downtown it was like right on the main
like main drag like corner and like I
said it was like there was that place
and then pizza place and then Police
Department where they are now
um they don't have as many problems
anymore because now they're in the
warehouse District so they're not
downtown so you don't get walking like
you basically have to it's not even um
you can't even see it from the road
actually you have to know where it is
you have to go back behind all these
other like warehouses and all this other
kind of [__] there's no sign there's
nothing
you just have to know where it's at
um so you don't get any like Randa is
walking in so it's like much safer I
don't even think they have bouncers
anymore they have a door guy that's
about it where where are we talking
about Barbarella oh Barbara Barbarella
doesn't need security no no like I said
nobody knows where it is yeah that's not
there's no sign there's no anything as
players only yeah it goes to that place
yeah it's like like I said it's in a
warehouse complex where everything else
is closed yeah and if you don't know
where it is you're not gonna find it
yeah you can go in there half dressed
there's a girl as safe as [__] because
there's nothing but seamsters and
there's no public it's awesome it's all
private as much as I loved their
downtown location like I loved that bar
I loved that location it was just there
was just something about it I mean it
was so cool like inside and there was
like such a great Vibe about it like
such great energy
um I loved that and I miss it yeah but
on the other hand like where it is now
is I feel much much safer yeah going
there because you know that like just
random ass people aren't gonna walk in
there's not people walking by going hey
let's go in here and [__] with these
people you know which used to happen at
the old place because it was right there
it's like right on the new drag what
happened Cove had hit and all the good
clubs downtown [__] went out of
business
and uh the [__] the landlords got
desperate and lowered all the rats and
shitty clubs moving and went ghetto as
[__] man shootings went up and everybody
just left and I it'll be years before
that [__] recovers
do you what is it what is it like now I
mean we haven't been I don't know I
haven't been down there I heard that
like a bar like a club opened up in Old
Barbarella but it closed again like
pretty quickly yeah I don't know if
that's the case but I thought that that
was what I heard and I thought it was
another country western bar which is
dumb because there's one right across
the street there's a country western bar
like right there like right across the
street from them I don't know why they
need another one
but yeah maybe maybe end up maybe ibar
will be able to get back in there
eventually I would like that because
like I said I do love that John might be
able to get back in I do love that
location yeah I don't love all the
random ass people walking in yeah and
all the [__] gag fighting and [__]
yeah like yeah it wasn't starting to get
dangerous yeah it wasn't super safe yeah
after after covet it got real dangerous
but it it the cops will get a hold of it
you just need to get [__] higher end
[__]
events going you know what I mean and
it'll push all the [__] Riff Raff out
yeah but you know like I said it's it's
kind of money got sucked out of downtown
it's kind of the same thing we're going
through with mannequins where
um you know a lot of people go there but
it's like a lot of people that go there
it's like it's not really yeah sure if
you want them to be there or not because
they're just causing trouble yeah
because it's right there like in the
main drag so everyone's just gonna
wander in yeah and that's never a good
look baseball caps rednecks and [__]
cargo shorts
[__] white and obnoxious ass
attitudes yeah what ass grabbing
[__] white hood rats and I
gotta fight every time I go there
I win but I gotta fight originally I'm
gonna run into a [__] who's
going to be crazier than me that's what
I mean it's like that's what eventually
what will happen that's why I worry
about it yeah I do like going there and
it's like it's stupid but I'm not that
stupid I know that eventually you're in
combat long enough your number will come
up yeah there's always a bigger fish and
I gotta keep fighting these
[__] because they keep grabbing
your ass and [__]
well yeah that was on Trend too it's a
it's not like having a short for you
there is no fuse I'll knock them over
yeah there is no fuse what are they
gonna do I'm a girl
you know and I'm having sex and violence
merging in and I'm beating the [__] out
of a [__] I'm going I'm gonna
rape you you just get mean as [__] uh
just crazy I don't want to be in that
situation anymore [__] the next thing
you know [__]
I'm not really worried about the law
here it doesn't it's not like a normal
place
um people here are not real this is not
a real litigious [__] culture if guys
fight they usually don't they just don't
go to the cops
you're like oh he hurt me you know
that's not gonna happen here
um
but if it gets real [__] violent you
know what I mean dude start shooting at
one another the cops have to get
involved and
we'll see and that's what I was kind of
worried about like that [__] that went
down before like where I got tackled and
stuff like that I'm like what you know
what would have happened if that dude
did happen like what if he had a knife
he was like on top of me if he had like
stabbed me in the [__] liver or
something like that I'd been dead you
know what I mean no you would have lived
but he wouldn't have but I mean he
wouldn't but he didn't know when he
[__] stopped that dude in a greasy
spot he I mean well once I recovered I
would have he saw what was left of him
but you know what I mean he would have
stomped him into a greasy spot but um
I'm just saying that that could have
happened because that that dude was well
yeah but all the more reason for him to
have something on him because he knew
that he couldn't like do anything with
his face the only reason why that
happens because they pulled me off yeah
well they tricked me and to stop
attacking
he tricked you Tom that girl [__] did
that yeah let him go I let him go and he
attacked you but they got him out they
they everybody else grabbed him so
quickly though
yeah I mean I didn't get hurt I was just
surprised yeah because I was like what
the [__] is happening right now he
thought you were me I guess I've been
ringing his Bell
well he and I once we told everybody
else that he didn't know it was you he
thought it was me he wasn't in his right
mind to start with I don't think I don't
know what the [__] he was on I don't
know if he was just really drunk or
really high or both or I don't really
know
we got to get back to the topic man well
I know it's like it's getting to be like
my bedtime is it but um but but yeah
that's what happened this has been a
good show though fun show
um here was a quote that I found very
interesting this was from
Stephen Novella and he was talking about
modern flat earthers
and uh one of the things that he said
because and this was something that Tom
said when I was telling him we were
doing a show about Flat Earth she's like
none of them really believe that come on
but then like I showed him because I had
watched uh the beginning of like the
documentary that was on 2B I'm like I
think some people actually might believe
I don't know if they deep down deep down
believe it but it's like they seem to
genuinely believe it so after he watched
it he's kind of like oh yeah I kind of
see what you're getting at but I think
that the reason they believe in the
things they don't believe in the things
for scientific reasons they don't
believe in them the same way that
someone who actually knows that the
Earth is round
um you know we don't just believe in it
for funsies or because it's like part of
our religious thing or anything like
that it's just that obviously that's
what all the scientific that's you know
that's what the uh consensus of
scientific evidence says so that's why
we believe it it doesn't matter to me
one way or the other if the Earth was
flat around it doesn't really matter I'm
just saying that we believe it's round
because of evidence whereas I feel like
flat earthers are largely coming at it
from as I said an emotional standpoint
or a psychological standpoint they have
other reasons for wanting to believe
this particular thing so they could be
religious reasons or they could be
social reasons or they could be like
lots of other things but one of the
things that Stephen Novella said he said
in the end
that is the core malfunction of the flat
earthers and the modern populist
rejection of expertise in general it is
a horrifically simplistic view of the
world that ignores partly out of
ignorance and partly out of motivated
reasoning to uh real complex
complexities of our civilization just so
he's saying that they people want things
to be simpler they don't understand
um complexities so
they want things to be simpler and so
they say that things are simple even
though they're not
um it's ultimately this is a quote again
lazy childish and self-indulgent
resulting in a profound level of
ignorance drowning in motivated
reasoning which uh is a quote that it's
a little harsh but I actually do agree
with that I'm not saying that a lot of
um the flat earther people didn't seem
like nice people they did
um but I just think they're very
misguided and I think they came to that
for reasons other than reason they
didn't use reason to get to that it's
cult activity it is it is very culty and
I thought you'd think this was funny
they the Flat Earth
um convention that they had in the UK
they had a guy there who was like a
skeptic like a big skeptic guy and he
went around and gave some of the flat
earthers like a um like a uh what do you
call it like a um
survey yeah now he didn't tell them what
the survey was for but he just like
asked them questions and stuff like that
the survey was actually like are you in
a cult type of thing or like how to know
if you're an occult yeah um and all of
them like like scored like really really
high like yeah it's like yeah yeah but
it's like they didn't like I I don't
think that they would um understand it
as them being an occult but it is even
just watching that documentary for an
hour and 40 minutes or however long it
was it's very very culty yeah and the
thing about it we were laughing about it
too because like I said there's a lot of
infighting between the different
factions like oh you know Dome or no
Dome infinite uh you know like [__]
and they're mean about yeah and they're
oh yeah they're and they're really
really [__] and that's what I mean
it's like it's hilarious and the the
woman Patricia Steele she was sitting
there and she supposedly like really
believes in this flatter thing [__] and
she believes in all the other conspiracy
theories too like pretty much all of
them
and she was like so even her
she got called she's like well at first
they started out calling me a shill
which was that's the kind of thing they
throw around and like the crazy guy was
even calling like the the um conference
that they were having in Raleigh it's
like he called it chill Fest or
something like that he he said everybody
everybody works for Warner Brothers and
they were all paid off and it was like
he was like living in a government safe
house and it's like it's just ridiculous
like this is she was trans yeah she's
like well that's the greatest thing
that's the latest thing she's like well
she's like I've been called a show she's
like I was called a reptilian and that
you could actually like see my eyes
change to like reptile eyes like in the
video
um she's like the latest thing is like
saying I'm trans or whatever which I
guess that's the latest buzzword like
for insulting somebody or whatever which
is [__] up I got good I got good
[__] radar growing up in Brazil they
had the best trans girls in the [__]
world were there okay that girl was not
trans
no way
no way it's just funny that they came up
with that [__] well like I said anything
way of messing with somebody right any
way of undermining because that's very
much in the Zeitgeist at the time and
it's like you know a lot of people are
like you know getting upset about that
so it's just kind of like oh that's what
we're gonna like that's a you know
that's an insult that we're gonna lie
about somebody
which is dumb but whatever so you know
so yeah she got accused of all oh and
this was my favorite thing she's like oh
and also said they said that I was a
government agent because my name is
Patricia she's like which is my birth
name and the last three letters of that
are CIA
yeah yeah that's right I was laughing
with the the CIA thing and she also said
oh and you know oh what did what she
said they called her a flat Earth honey
pot that's right A Flat Earth Honeypot
so in other words the enemy is sending
you a good looking woman so you can be
attracted to her and then she can [__]
up your flat Earth [__]
um theories
ain't that something a honey a flat
Earth honey
and they said yes
she's steering women in the wrong
direction because her last name is steer
with an ear with an e at the end only
dudes could come up with some [__] like
that that's awesome
yeah very Advanced because dudes
[Laughter]
these dudes come I'm like are you guys
[__] serious
what is the matter with these people
what is the matter with these people I
don't understand that that's a stroke of
Genius I don't understand
look I just look I have very very little
patience for stupidity and I especially
have it's just that's so stupid this
genius no it's it's really not it's
really not and especially and I
especially have zero patience for
willful stupidity willful stupidity or
willful ignorance
like you know that what you're saying is
[__] but you're like saying it
anyway yeah
pisses me off a lot
Jenny Jenny sometimes [__] she gets
mad you know like
dudes will come up with some [__]
awesome burns on somebody you know what
I mean but they're not awesome dudes
they're dumb dudes grow up fighting with
each other
something creative we call each other
names if they came up with something
creative I'd be like all right nice one
but they never do it so it's like just
roll up it's always [__] with each
other and making up names
I have brothers and she doesn't get that
yeah but it doesn't have to be true it
doesn't even have to be real it just has
to be funny as [__]
and really the more nonsensical the
funnier it is the more effective it is
on other men
other misses but like I said I
understand all that I get all that it's
just that most of the time one it's not
clever and two it's not funny I thought
[__] Flat Earth was [__] funny
it's kind of funny but I'm just kind of
like what's ridiculous yeah it is
ridiculous but but yeah I think what
made it effective though the CIA thing
at the end of the at the end of her name
was funnier to me just because I'm like
what [__] came up with that yeah like
there it is right there CIA it's like a
lot of people are named Patricia I guess
they all work for the CIA or or Marsha
if you're named Marshall you work for
the CIA her parents named her that uh
knowing that she would one day join the
CIA I guess so everything's a
conspiracies you get into that mindset
okay
gave her that name as a code name but
you see they have to have a legal
disclaimer okay it says CIA in it so
therefore she's not technically
undercover they're not breaking any laws
hey because it says right there
that's some [__] thing that's that yeah
yeah well and the weird here's what kind
of made me mad about that whole
discussion where she was telling the
documentary filmmaker about all the [__]
that had been lobbed at her like all the
hate that she got you know she's a
pretty woman
so she's not young she's probably I
don't know she's probably like mine yeah
she okay look is
for you men out there she's cute she's
cute yeah uh 40 plus between four you
know she's maybe Jen's age close to 50
maybe uh well preserved good figure I
look like she had implants
pretty face she is intelligent and very
pleasant Smith's fan yeah Smith fans you
know she's intelligent and um
entertaining uh she's wrong
yeah about Earth being flat she's
delusional or it's it's it's a way of
getting involved in the cult
okay it's more like a cult thing it is
more than anything else
but and we've said the same stuff about
scientologists is that that's what to me
that's what's so frustrating about them
is that and her in particular she was
like telling the documentary filmmaker
about all of this stuff that other flat
earthers like in other little factions
had lobbed at her and all the stupid
conspiracy theories that they made up
about her
and yet she wasn't able to take it that
extra level and say oh well maybe all of
this is [__] too because all the
[__] that they're saying is [__] so
maybe this is also [__] like she
didn't really she couldn't really apply
the same because she knew that was
[__] obviously she's like sitting
there going because she even said oh
yeah they said that I was on the CIA
payroll because my name is Patricia and
the last three letters are CIA she's
like and like the government would be
that dumb and I'm like well why don't
you just take that another step further
and like figure out hey this whole thing
is like this whole conspiracy [__]
you're into because she was into like a
lot of other conspiracy theories too but
it's like she seemed like she was smart
enough to get that like when it was
personal when it was applied to her but
she couldn't like extrapolate like to
the bigger picture and that was like
really frustrating to me yeah because
she she seemed like a very intelligent
woman and I don't I don't know it's just
like it makes me mad and I just want to
smack people like that
because it seems like they're they're
all they're most of the way there
they frustrate you they're frustrating
well because it's like they're not dumb
they're not and it's like that you know
he's in this situation because it serves
her needs yeah it's so and I know that
it's just like it's more a psychological
thing I get that like I get it's I know
I know that
um it's hard for me to understand
because I don't have those yeah that
psychological need in that way uh that
would make me want to join a group like
that or or anything so it's like it's
hard for me so it's very frustrating for
me like seeing people that are otherwise
intelligent falling into that kind of
stuff well there's it's the same thing
as religion
there are people involved in religions
they're normal people they're living
good lives they're intelligent if you
actually look at the details of what
that religion believes in
it it's gonna be a range of things some
of it's crazy other other parts that are
common sense other parts of it are
morality Tales you know what I mean it's
a mixture of stuff
even people who are involved in
religions
can look at their own religion sometime
and go yeah that's [__] but I
believe the rest of it
right
yeah like Noah's Ark you go yeah maybe
there was a flood but there couldn't
have been two of each kind of in in that
and yeah when you think about the
logistics
that's just a story that they're telling
us so plus that story as well that
doesn't mean I'm not a Christian you
know
even though what's funny about
Christians and you know I come from a
Christian background I'm an ex-christian
I used to I grew up believing it but
then as I got older you know my teens I
was like nah there's not enough there
that that's you know this is this is
Legend and Fable and no
but uh
oh [__] I forgot where I was going
[Laughter]
um can't blame me this time I didn't say
it again
you know it doesn't matter
I'll remember later I was just saying
that you know that
there's
religions all have [__] weird
elements to them and I think most of the
Believers are picking certain things out
going that couldn't have actually
happened but you know what I mean the
rest of the shit's all right just it's
more cultural I think than anything else
I mean everyone does that everyone just
picks and shoes picks and chooses what
they want to believe and well that
that's another thing that kind of
frustrates me is that like people who
you know ostensibly on their face like
quote unquote don't believe in science
or distrust science they use science all
the time to discern which of the
biblical stories they're going to
believe and which ones they think are
ridiculous because it's like you're
applying a standard to that where do you
think that standard is coming from it's
not coming from the Bible because that's
what you're you're outside of that like
looking in at it so
they're not believing in science things
that they say I don't think it's
actually not believing and they use
science every single day yeah right and
they use toasters and electricity and
cars and that kind of stuff a lot of
[__] that wouldn't work if a lot of
their beliefs were true what they're
talking about is they're saying that the
authorities are lying to us about the
truth so they're sending scientists at
us but these aren't real scientists
these are shill scientists that are
trying to protect us from the truth the
truth is that the Earth is flat
that's not logical it's easier if the
Earth was flat it would be easier for
rulers to just go yeah it's flat
because then you know you don't and come
up with something like to control you
some other because some other way
because it would cost too much money to
to hide the fact and like I said why
would they bother why would they bother
if the okay the amount of money the
juice wouldn't be worth the squeeze
there's other exactly that's what I'm
saying like let's just say
hypothetically that the Earth was flat
one what would be the motivation for
making everybody over hundreds over
centuries Millennia yeah think that it
was round even though I mean even though
you can plainly see that it's round yeah
and you know the ancient Greeks knew
that it was around like one what would
be the motivation
and two it's like what like what would
be the logistics behind that like what
all of the [__] that you would that
would have to be faked over the last
like I said centuries Millennia all the
photos that would have to have been
fakes all the books all the you know
everything like all the testimonies that
have to be fixed all the math that would
happen
top down
and there really is no top the players
in the tops changed over the decades
that's what yeah this would be taking
place over centuries you couldn't hold
it together for long long enough no
that's what I'm saying I kind of feel
like a lot of people with these
conspiratorial mindset especially like
the tend toward like these Global
conspiracies yeah you kind of think that
one there's like these these people at
the top that are always
running [__] that are always that and
everybody has the same idea and they're
all on the same page and [__] like that
that's not how Humanity Works humans are
I mean
chaotic you're never going to get two
people to agree on anything like much
less like over
centuries yeah like you're never gonna
get everybody on the same page for that
[__] shit's gonna leak out it's just
like there's just no way there's no way
there is some stuff though that
is questionable okay
um like for instance if you can get into
it the concept of fossil fuels all right
um
the story that the oil companies have
agreed to stay here in western
civilization
is that oil
comes from fossils and old plant life
and dinosaurs from millions of years ago
it is somehow that it turns into oil
through a process
other people and outside the western
civilization say no it's not what it is
what it is it's carbon and hydrogen
under intense heat pressure making
hydrocarbons
you could do that you can take coal and
hydrogen and under a lot of heat and
pressure make synthetic oil
all right the Germans were doing it in
World War II a long time ago
it stands the reason that the concept of
fossil fuel was an invention of the oil
industry
to inflate the value of their oil to
make it seem like a rare commodity
um and this is bore out by the moon
Titan going around Jupiter it's covered
in oil
coal is everywhere carbon is [__]
very common so is hydrogen they're the
two most common elements in the universe
I personally do not believe that oil is
fossil has anything to do with fossils I
think it's just coal the earth form with
a bunch of coal during its form
formation process because there's a
bunch of collisions that even caused the
moon and coal which is just carbon it's
[__] super common coal and hydrogen
and the hydrogen came from [__] the
Kuiper belt
deep down on the Earth's crust there's a
bunch of [__] coal and hydrogen makes
its way down under there underneath the
heat and pressure it makes oil
it probably constantly makes it
so it's probably replenished
but that wouldn't be any that wouldn't
be in the interest of the oil industry
they would rather it be like gold where
it was on made once a long time ago and
there's a limited amount of it
I'm sure you could burn it up maybe if
you had enough [__] you could probably
burn it up faster than it was being
produced and then maybe it's finite
maybe you eventually run out of coal
but that's just one thing I was talking
about about maybe conspiracy theory
would the or would the oil Industries
conspire with each other to have an
alternate explanation of where Oil comes
from
because the Russians don't believe in
fossil fuel
they say that it's just carbon and
hydrogen hydrocarbons and it's on Titan
and you know there were no dinosaurs or
life on Titan
sitting there on the surface of it
coal seems to be everywhere
so it's hydrogen anyway that's just an
example
so just because it's a conspiracy theory
doesn't mean it's wrong but you got to
test it
and some of the [__] well I mean there
has to be evidence for it you can't just
come at it and just assume that there's
a conspiracy and then look for free
because you're just gonna cherry pick
[__] that's how that that's confirmation
bias yeah you can't come at it thinking
there's already something it's like you
know you just have to like investigate
and see where the [__] takes you you
know what I mean and I I just I don't
know I just kind of feel like Tammy's
like 13 o'clock is fake there is no Tom
and Jenny there is no Thomas it's only
Pookie is put yeah Pookie is running the
whole [__] Pookie's controlling an AI
program she is here you heard it here
first yeah we're admitting it making a
fake Tom and Jerry yeah
she made yeah she made
um little like digital avatars of us
that that would take care of her yeah
and then also occasionally do live
streams
can we talk for a minute because I think
somebody brought it up earlier
about
Mike Hughes who was a uh flat earther
who decided that he was gonna build
a rocket
to launch himself up into
uh space well space but like the lower
atmosphere
so he could prove that the Earth was
flat because he was like oh I need to
get up in the house so I can see the
curvature even though you can see the
curvature like from a plane
I mean I've seen the curvature of the
Earth from a plane you could just get in
a plane you don't have to like buy a
[__] you can just watch Elon musk's
Rockets take off and see if they think
they think all that is fake because
obviously everyone would like really
make all that effort to like fake
something just for your dumb ass sure
but yeah so this guy like built a rocket
and he was trying to get and um so
he did it a couple I think he did it
once or twice and it's like he lived but
he very famously
um crash landed and died
doing this stuff now afterward
um I think like his uh PR representative
said oh he wasn't really a flat earther
and he didn't really want that but I'm
pretty sure that he had gone out in the
media and said that he was doing that
whole stunt to prove that the Earth was
flat like he was building a rocket and
it cost like twenty thousand dollars
like his first one like he raised all
this money and like went up into the
[__] but yeah he ended up crashing
and dying so he literally did die for
his beliefs apparently and what did it
prove probably nothing
I don't know just
it's just I don't know it's this kind of
[__] it's just something that is just so
fundamental and so obvious
that you could
I don't know I feel like they just like
being contrarian Maybe
or being defiant or they're or they're
just so down that rabbit hole of
everything is fake we're in The Matrix
like those people
which like I said whether we're in The
Matrix or not there's no way you could
prove it it's not falsifiable so it's
like what [__] difference does it
make really
you can't prove that one way or the
other you know what I'm saying
so I I don't really feel like it's not a
very productive like Avenue of argument
because it's not falsifiable you can't
argue it one way or the other so I can't
I don't know I I just kind of feel like
these people that are going against
hundreds or thousands of years of
established science like creationists or
flat earthers I kind of feel like
they're they just want to be contrarian
yeah maybe because they want to feel
special I don't really know why I don't
know why I'm not them and I don't know
what their psychology is like I'm not
like that so I don't really
resonate with it
but I don't know they frustrate me and
like I said it's I I was watching like
some Flat Earth videos and stuff like
that but I had to stop and like just go
over to like debunking ones that just
showed like clips of the other ones
because I was just kind of like I can't
watch that much concentrated stupid and
like one
go it gives me a headache so I was just
kind of like
just just the the obvious mistakes they
were making
um you know just just fundamental [__]
like fundamental [__] if you took
physics if you took like anything like
that like you would know that they were
not correct and yet they were talking as
though they were like authorities on
[__] and it's like I hate that kind of
[__] anybody that's kind of like that's
all done in Kruger like that that's just
kind of like obviously doesn't know
anything but their talking is though
well obviously like that like those well
actually [__] but they don't
know what they're talking about it's
like that just really really that gets
right up my nose and I'm just like I
just want to hit that person really
really hard I hate that smug stupidity
kind of [__] and that's exactly like
what these [__] were like so I
just wanted to like smack them but yeah
so it's getting kind of late maybe we
should go yeah it's getting 10 o'clock
anyway it is yeah I probably have to go
to sleep soon because I have to get up
at five
yeah like go to work again tomorrow but
this has been kind of a fun show even
though they're kind of like made me mad
Jay's got what her new dress is on it
looks so cute boobs are just [__]
spilling out to the top but guys don't
have the proper angle and then I gotta
go to sleep and she's gonna I gotta get
in bed with this woman she's just gonna
go to sleep that's what I do you know
how it is well I mean I might not but
you know what I mean
but I'll be really cranky tomorrow I'm
too cranky man I'll be really crazy
tomorrow it's okay we'll [__] we'll
we'll hook up later
Poor Tom yeah it's okay
Ben says do a poll about what I don't
know he's talking about other people
were cheering in uh also uh talking
about abiotic oil yeah I don't believe
oil has anything to do with life it's
probably pretty common it's volcanic
activity carbon and hydrogen which is
water
being pressure cooked at high [__]
down in the CR down inside underneath
the mantle and [__] you're pressure
cooking it I mean [__] the uh the
Germans were making it even back in the
[__] 40s
so nah it's
it doesn't have anything to do with life
you're gonna find that [__] on lifeless
planets and moons and [__] like Titan
it's just evidently according to NASA
and I saw it on NASA's website
that oil hydrocarbons sit on the surface
of [__] Titan is they're talking
about oil
Ben said we should do a poll on whether
the Earth is flat or a globe yeah Paul
will tell us the truth won't it
no yeah that's the way science tells you
and experimentation and data
you could go back into Europe you know
Middle Ages France and do a poll and
they would tell you the dog heads
existed
you know what a dog head is it's a
person with has a head of a dog the dog
head they would call them dog heads and
they believed that they existed but they
existed somewhere else
and the church was fine with it because
they're Christians the dog heads are
Christians too they're good people they
believe with those things existed yeah
their heads are a very good boy and it
was all uh
a myth Tammy said I think the Earth is a
cube
[__] Triangle Man well I mean
somebody put I was watching a video
earlier that pointed out they're like
even if the Earth was flat they're like
you know how one of the arguments that
the flat roosters make is like oh well I
look at the Horizon and it looks flat
he's like guess what he's like look at
this like pizza pan that I have a pizza
pan and he's like even if the Earth was
a flat disc like this pizza pan it's
like if you photographed it he's like
guess what it would still look [__]
curved like from the [__] so he's like I
don't know what you're talking about
like I don't know what this argument is
like you're the [__]
Horizon looks flat therefore and he's
like and it doesn't look like he's like
actually if you have like a really good
camera
and you um take a picture of like a uh
of the Horizon he's like you'll see that
there is a very very slight curve he's
like it's very slight and you need you
know if you don't obviously have like a
great deal of distance but he's like if
you um have like a really good camera
and take a picture of it and like blow
it up and everything like that you will
see a very slight curvature
it's not flat he's like so even if it
was flat it would still look curved
anyway so he's like I don't know what
you guys are talking about
um and Sebastian said what about the UN
map oh yeah that was another argument
that they used
like I said what this is the same this
is on the same level as saying like
Patricia has CIA at the end so therefore
she works for the CIA
they basically said well because the UN
logo looks like the Flat Earth Map yeah
then okay then everybody that like the
elites know that the Earth is flat and
like they're somehow like winking at
everybody like saying oh we're gonna use
it for our logo like to make fun of the
ribs I don't even know what the like
[__] logic is behind that but it's
like they used that because it's like
they got so they could get all the
countries that were in the U.N in the
logo obviously
like because if you just do the globe
yeah there's only going to be half the
countries on the you know what I mean
because you're not gonna be able to see
the other side of it so they're gonna
put all the Earth all the all the
country close this show out
there are some people
in the course of watching this show that
are gonna try to bend over backwards to
stop these flat orders from believing
what they believe in it's a waste of
time
it doesn't matter if they think the
world is flat or not
it's not gonna hurt anybody I don't
believe because there's a lot of other
people that believe [__] that's even
more destructive that isn't true well I
think people the reason people are
concerned about flatters is because
those things tend to go together like
people that are flat earthers also tend
to believe in other more destructive uh
then all of a sudden you're worried
about thought crime well because you
believe this well no one's saying that
puts you in prison
you just got to be careful no one's
imprisoning anybody because of what do
they think yeah not yet no I'm just
saying that well like I said before look
I don't give a [__] what people believe
you can believe whatever crazy [__] you
gotta break a law to go to prison yeah
yeah
yeah like no one is saying that like
anyone should be imprisoned or anything
like that for [__] they believe that's
ridiculous I'm just saying that as long
as other countries do it
it's ridiculous it's still ridiculous
other countries do it it's objectively
ridiculous is what I'm saying like I
don't care if other countries do it that
doesn't mean it's right I'm just saying
that you know as long as it stays in
your head and it's not really like
impacting other people in any meaningful
way then that's fine you can believe
whatever crazy [__] you want you can
believe Santa Claus is real I just give
that belief I don't give a crap about
that it is my belief that believing that
the Earth is flat will cause no damage
to society or the Earth because well
there aren't really enough there's not
one there's not enough of them two what
kind of Technology what kind of
destructive technology are you gonna
make based upon well they're not going
to make [__] yeah it's not gonna work if
your science stops at Earth being flat
then that means you don't know even
basic physics you're not you're going to
be able to make [__] atomic bombs
okay you're not gonna be able to make
anything that would be a a threat to
civilization you're just going to be
wrong that's a good way of putting it
okay that's a good way to put it you're
not Advanced enough to make anything
dangerous uh
I mean that's pre-gun powder thinking
it is yeah when you put it that way yeah
yeah okay I'm not worried about it
but like I said I find it interesting
the same way that I find creationism
interesting just because it's
interesting to me just the way and and
like I said it's this kind of mindset
it's not just confined to Flat Earth or
it's not just confined to Creations but
they you know they tend to believe a lot
of other crazy [__] too but the thing
about it is that it's a whole
it it's a whole world view whole mindset
that they're coming at things from which
is maybe dangerous in other contexts but
like you said because they don't
understand science they probably can't
really do anything they don't want to
understand it okay yeah they can't or
they won't the only day they're probably
capable the only danger they pose is to
themselves okay
like that one dude was a lunatic
clearly you know uh and he's not in this
program that we watched he he wanted a
certain percentage of it I could just
tell by his mannerisms of the tone of
his voice that [__] was a
lunatic
he's the kind of guy that would do
something kind of like a Jim Jones
okay where he again
and make something completely kind of
vibe yeah where they're gonna have to
[__] exit the world and meet up with
the hellbopp Comet or some stupid [__]
when I was right there's no hell it's
the hail Bop balloon that's gonna go by
you know uh something they're they're
yeah they're gonna go that's the biggest
danger they're gonna go and try to like
go past the ice wall yeah that's the
biggest dangerous and then they're gonna
get lost at sea exactly biggest danger
is like they hurt themselves trying to
prove this Theory that's not not gonna
happen like the dude that like crashed
like trying to prove that it was flat in
this rocket yeah when you're um but the
thing is is that I'm gonna go back to
what I said before
I think most of the people that believe
this are just along for the scene and
the ride
I don't think they'd put their life on
the line for it because I think they
doubt or know that it isn't true
they got a lot of Christians that know
it isn't true
well yeah that's what I mean just
because you say Christian and Christian
doesn't necessarily imply creationism
either that's usually like a
fundamentalist strain of Christianity
most Christians accept evolution yeah
you know yeah most Christians are not
real backwards they're just like
cultural Christians and you know the
same way you know they've got cultural
Islam out there where they're like yeah
yeah that's what the religion says but
you know hey we gotta well you know we
see how [__] really yeah we gotta do
[__] today okay we're talking about
right now yeah you know and and that's
and I yeah I feel like that the majority
of people are just like just day-to-day
life they're just like dealing with [__]
in their day-to-day life they're not
really that into it so you're kind of
getting
you know we hear a lot about these kind
of just like small Fringe of people
because their beliefs are obviously like
way outside the norm and they're like
[__] crazy and like they do crazy
[__] sometimes like the dude that
crashed like building Rockets yeah the
Earth was flat
but you know what I mean uh did he
succeed he did not and I don't really
see how anybody could succeed you can't
succeed it's not flat it's just not yeah
I just like I'm sorry to burst your
bubble about that but it just isn't
Evolution happened the Earth is a sphere
yeah I'm sorry to like happen yes
Sebastian werewolves Werewolves are
reality they're created by uh something
called Trenbolone
yeah you'll become a werewolf after
about five months of that [__]
because I was thinking about doing a
werewolf whoever crossed costume for
like um for the show and off or not for
this show but for the other projects
shooting porn and also for Halloween
yeah yeah yeah so I was thinking about
that and then um that would just be
furry sex wouldn't it probably yeah
that's what it is so the yeah he sent me
like this weird and I'm at work too and
he's gonna be like this weird GIF of
like this werewolf he's like this is me
and you
it's just I gotta get a dog park gotta
get a dog paw [__] adhesive fake
tattoo put that on your booty
like Adam we were talking about
something else and he just said that
like randomly and I'm just like okay
that's random but all right funny
this is what we talked about here's
somebody [__] honk a horn yeah
somebody was talking a horn outside okay
we're fine all right so we're gonna wrap
this up because I really really have to
go yeah yeah this is getting really
really late yeah and I have to get it
very it's the super chats people thank
you very much for the super chats thank
you for dropping remember there's a
super thanks if you're listening to this
recorded super thanks or activated yeah
Tammy said shut this [__] down Jenny
shut that [__] down I'm trying to I'm
trying to all right so uh we will see
you guys again uh Friday night for the
Sidetrack show which should be super fun
I don't know what we're gonna talk about
I never know what we're gonna talk about
but that's part of the fun of the show
so hopefully you guys can join us again
on Friday night have a good rest of your
evening you guys and have a good day
tomorrow and we'll see you guys again on
Friday night